ओके
सो आई थिंक वी आर
लाइव यस यस यस यस वी आर लाइव
राइट
ओके सो हम लाइव
है लेट मी चेक वंस एक बार मुझे देखने देना
कि मैं लाइव आ चुका हूं हूं या नहीं सब
कुछ ओके है एम आ लाइव गाइस एवरीथिंग इज
ओके प्लीज लेट मी नो ऑडियो वीडियो सब सही
मस्त बिंदास बता दीजिए मुझे जल्दी से सब
कुछ सही है ना ऑडियो वीडियो एवरीथिंग इ
फाइन प्लीज लेट मी नो गाइस इज एवरीथिंग
फाइन ओके ऑडियो वीडियो सब सही
है
चलिए जल्दी से मुझे इफॉर्म कर दीजिए जल्दी
से बता दीजिए
यस गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग टू
एवरीबॉडी गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग
सबको गुड इवनिंग चलिए
तो आने देते हैं सभी लोग को एक बार जल्दी
से एंड वेलकम एवरी बडी टू डे टू सेकंड
क्लास ऑफ बग बाउटी वेलकम वेलकम एवरी बडी
देखते हैं कि कल जितने लोग आए थे उतने आज
आते हैं कि नहीं कल वाले रिपीट करते हैं
कि नहीं करते
हैं बिकॉज लाइव क्लास के कुछ अलग ही मजे
हैं ठीक है और आज का भी टॉपिक काफी
इंपॉर्टेंट है काफी इंपॉर्टेंट काफी मैं
बताऊंगा कैसे क्या है तो सबसे पहले
स्टेप्स टू सक्सेस क्या है आपके कीप
लर्निंग एंड प्रैक्टिसिंग बी अ लर्नर
अर्निंग विल कम फोकस ऑन कांसेप्सड सेट योर
टारगेट एंड उसके अकॉर्डिंग प्लान करना है
जैसा कि आप देख सकते हैं ठीक है ये आपके
स्टेप्स होने चाहिए सक्सेस के लिए एंड ये
स्टेप्स आप बग बाउंट में भी बग हंटिंग में
भी आप इंक्लूड करने वाले हैं ठीक है अगर
आप एक बग हंटर बनना चाहते इंक्लूड दीज
स्टेप्स एंड यू विल बिकम अ प्रोप गंड इट्स
माय गारंटी ठीक है
चलिए
ओके एक दिन का एक दिन का गैप तो रहेगा
मैंने जैसे ही मैंने बताया था ऑलरेडी आपको
कि एक दिन का मिनिमम गैप रहेगा कभी-कभी दो
दिन का भी गैप रह सकता है बट मिनिमम वन डे
गैप विल बी देयर ताकि जो मैं बताऊं आप
उसको प्रोसेस कर पाओ पढ़ पाओ एंड अपने से
खुद से भी कुछ और एक्सप्लोर कर पाओ उसको
लेके तभी वन डे का गैप आपको दिया जा रहा
है ठीक है तो उसको आप यूटिलाइज करना है
उसको छोड़ना नहीं है एंड एंड एंड प्लीज आप
बहुत अच्छे से सीखना चाहते हैं आप एक प्रो
हंटर बनना चाहते हैं यू नीड टू बी विद मी
यू नीड टू अलाइन विद मी आपको मेरे साथ-साथ
चलना है बस आप मेरे साथ साथ चलो यू विल
बिकम इट्स माय गारंटी ठीक है तो गारंटी
मैं देते जा रहा हूं बस आपको वो काम करना
है अगर काम नहीं करोगे तो फिर कोई फायदा
नहीं है अब मुझे सच सच बता दो एकदम एकदम
एकदम सच मुझे बता दो एकदम सही सही प्रॉमिस
करके मुझे बताओ मतलब झूठ बिल्कुल नहीं
बोलना ऑनेस्टी बताना है कि आप में से
कितने लोगों ने ट्राई हैक मी पे फ्री या
प्रीमियम अकाउंट बनाया मतलब फ्री अकाउंट
में बना के साइन अप करके लॉगिन किया या तो
अगर किसी ने प्रीमियम लिया है तो वो भी
वेल एंड गुड वो आपको कभी भी रिग्रेट नहीं
करने का मौका देगा प्र अगर आप प्रीमियम
अकाउंट भी ले चुके हैं तो तो कितने लोगों
ने लॉग इन किया है मुझे जल्दी बता दीजिए
कितने लोगों ने कर लिया है मुझे सच-सच
बताना झूठ मत बोलना मेरे से प्लीज लेट मी
नो इन द चैट जल्दी
जल्दी सर आपने चेकलिस्ट नहीं डाली परसों
चेकलिस्ट डाल दी है डाल दी है स्कल क्रशर
मैंने चेकलिस्ट ऑलरेडी डाल दी है गाइस ओ
चेकलिस्ट एप्लीकेशन के अंदर में अगर आप
जैसे स्कल स्कल क्या है क्रशर ने बोलने
बोला है कि सर आपने चेकलिस्ट नहीं डाली तो
मैं आपको दिखा भी देता हूं कि मैंने डाली
है कि नहीं डाली है ठीक
है चलो मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं ऐसा नहीं
है यार मैंने डाला है तो डाला है यार देखो
देखो अभी फोन का स्क्रीन आ जाएगा तुम्हारे
सामने दिखेगा अभी सब कुछ यह देखो फोन की
स्क्रीन दिख रही होगी तुम्हें
मेरे देखो मैंने कहा कहां डाला है मैं
चलता हूं डेनिक्स एप्लीकेशन पे वेयर इज
डेनिक्स एप्लीकेशन डेनिक्स एप्लीकेशन पे
चलते
हैं आपको डिक्स एप्लीकेशन प जाना है जाना
है एंड आपको क्या करना
है यह फ्री कोर्स वाले में जाना है फ्री
कोर्स वाले में आप इसमें अगर नहीं है जॉइन
तो इसको जवाइन कर लीजिएगा ठीक
है इसमें ना के बराबर आपको कुछ नहीं लगने
इसमें आपके कंटेंट प जाना है कंटेंट प जब
आप जाओगे तो यहां बग बाउंट रिसोर्सेस की
एक मैंने डायरेक्टरी बनाई है आपको इस पर
चले जाना है एंड यहां ओस की चेकलिस्ट आपको
मिल जाएगी आपको इसको जिप फाइल है क्योंकि
जिप या पीडीएफ ही अलाउ करते हैं यहां पे
तो इसलिए जिफ फाइल मैंने डाल दी इसके अंदर
आपको एक्सेल की फाइल मिल जाएगी चेकलिस्ट
की ठीक
है बाकी कितने लोगों ने चेक लिस्ट को देखा
है क्योंकि आपने अगर ऐप को इंस्टॉल करा है
और आपने अगर इसमें इनरोल करा है जवाइन करा
है इस कोर्स को फ्री वाले तो आपको 110 पर
चेकलिस्ट जब डली होगी तो आपको नोटिफिकेशन
भी आई होगी कितने लोगों ने कर लिया है
ओके काफी लोगों ने ट्राई हैक मी पे एक
अकाउंट बना लिया है काफी लोगों ने नहीं भी
बनाया है देखो मैं बता रहा हूं आपको
क्रिएट करना है अकाउंट आपको यह काम करना
है इट्स मैंडेटरी आप ट्राई हैक मी को नहीं
छोड़ सकते यू कांट लीव ट्राई हैक मी यू
कांट स्टार्ट योर बग बाउंट जर्नी विदाउट
ट्राई हैक मी बिलीव मी जो मैं बोलू वो
करते चलो यार प्लीज इट्स माय रिक्वेस्ट
करोगे और आगे बढ़ो ग उसी अकॉर्डिंग जैसे
मैं बता रहा हूं ना तो तुम वो अचीव करोगे
जो तुम सोच रहे हो इट्स माय गारंटी यहां
पे मैं देखो यहां में आराम से तुम्हें ना
जो कंटेंट प्रोवाइड कर रहा हूं ये कंटेंट
तुम्हें पेड ट्रेनिंग में मिलेंगे बग
बांटी के बहुत सारे पेड ट्रेनिंग होते हैं
ठीक है इंटरनेट में बहुत सारे लोग कोर्सेस
प्रोवाइड करते हैं ट्रेनिंग प्रोवाइड करते
हैं वो कंटेंट आपको यहां फ्री में मिल रहा
है तो आपको उसके अकॉर्डिंग फॉलो तो कर लो
यार इतना तो मैं बोल रहा हूं और तो कुछ
बोल नहीं रहा और इस स्ट्रीम को अपने
दोस्तों के भी शेयर करो यार तभी तो पता
चलेगा उनको भी कि भैया यहां पे बग बांटी
की फ्री कोर्स चल रही है ठीक
है चलो बढ़िया देखते हैं देखते हैं तो
चलिए ओके गाइस सो आज का जो टॉपिक होने
वाला है आप सबको पता चल ही गया है दिस
टॉपिक इज चूज इंग अ राइट टारगेट अब आपको
ना ये लग रहा होगा थोड़ा कि ये क्या टॉपिक
है कि हाउ टू चूज अ राइट टारगेट इसमें कौन
सी बड़ी बात है राइट टारगेट चूज करने में
इसमें कौन सी ऐसी कोई कोई ऐसी बड़ी बात तो
नहीं लग रही है कि एक एक टारगेट को चूज
करना राइट टारगेट को अब मैं आपको इसका ना
एक छोटा सा एग्जांपल आपको समझाता हूं देखो
तुम एक बिगनर हो हो ठीक है एक बाग बाउंट
में तुम बिगनर हो एब्सलूट बिगनर हो मैं
बोलता हूं कुछ नहीं आता है कुछ भी नहीं
पता है कुछ नहीं जानते हो एंड उस टाइम पे
जब तुम हंट करना शुरू करते हो ना किसी अ
टारगेट पे किसी प्रोग्राम पे उस टाइम पे
ना तुम्हें समझ नहीं आता तुम कोई सा भी
टारगेट चूज करते हो उसपे हंट करना शुरू कर
देते हो एंड उसके बाद एंड किसी भी वनबिल
को फाइंड करने लगते हो और उसके बाद क्या
होता है ना उसके बाद तुम्हें डुप्लीकेट्स
मिलते हैं नॉट एप्लीकेबल बग्स मिलते हैं
एंड जब तुम्हें नॉट एप्लीकेबल डुप्लीकेट्स
बहुत ज्यादा मिलने लगते हैं तो तुम्हें
में डी मोटिवेशन होता है हालांकि ये जो
नॉट एप्लीकेबल मिलते हैं या डुप्लीकेट्स
मिलते हैं दीज आर एक्चुअल पार्ट्स ऑफ योर
बग बाउटी जर्नी बट उसको मिनिमाइज करना है
अब उसी को लेके थोड़ी ना चलना है यार अब
उसी को थोड़ी ना हमेशा आगे लेके चलना है
नहीं मुझे डुप्लीकेट्स ही चाहिए हमेशा ऐसा
नहीं है यार डुप्लीकेट्स मिलना इज अ
नॉर्मल थिंग बट उसको मिनिमाइज करना ये
आपके स्किल्स के अंदर आता है उसको
मिनिमाइज करना है कैसे मेथड से मेथड मतलब
उसका ये पहला पार्ट है बग बाउंट जर्नी का
वेरी फर्स्ट थिंग इज चूज इंग अ राइट
टारगेट चूज इंग अ राइट टारगेट ठीक है अब
देखो एक आप में से एक बंदा ऐसा भी है
जिन्होंने यहां चैट में लिखा है इफ आई
अर्न 8 लाख का डाला है फ्रॉम वक बाउंट हाउ
मच टैक्स आई नीड टू पे भैया पहले तो आप
पहले अर्न तो करो यार पहले टैक्स और 8 लाख
की बात करने लगे मैंने बोला ना माइंड को
मोनेटरी नहीं बनानी है ऐसा नहीं बनाना है
भाई कि बग बाउंट कर रहा हूं तो मुझे पैसे
चाहिए इसलिए कर रहा हूं नहीं पैसे
ऑटोमेटिक आएंगे यार आएंगे बट थोड़ा उसको
यार अभी साइड करो सीखने पे ध्यान दो क्या
यार तुम भी यार ऐसी बातें करोगे कैसे काम
चलेगा यार है
ना
चलिए चलिए ओके अभी करंट क्वेश्चन पे ध्यान
दे लो यार करंट
क्वे
ओके अच्छा कुछ लोग कुछ लोग मे मे मेरे से
भी पूछ रहे थे सर्टिफिकेशन का तो मैं एक
सीईए हूं एंड आई एम आरएच सीएसए ठीक है
हालांकि आई डोंट वैल्यू सर्टिफिकेशंस वो
मैंने कर लिए थे वैसे ही लोगों को दिखाने
के लिए सर्टिफिकेशंस दैट्ची तो चलिए अब
राइट टारगेट कैसे चूज करते हैं मेन टॉपिक
पे आते हैं अब टारगेट चूज करने का मतलब
क्या होता है मतलब ये होता है कि आप कौन
सी टारगेट को कौन सा ऐसा डोमेन या एड
एप्लीकेशन या मोबाइल एप्लीकेशन या कौन सी
कंपनी को चूज करेंगे जिस पे आप हंट करने
वाले हैं जिस पे यू आर गोइंग टू हंट ऑन ये
सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट स्टेप है बग बाउंट जर्नी
का सबसे पहला एंड सबसे इंपॉर्टेंट स्टेप
क्योंकि जब अगर आप टारगेट सही चूज नहीं
करेंगे ना तो आपको डुप्लीकेट मिलते रहेंगे
आपको सही से बाउंटीज नहीं मिल पाएंगी आपको
सही से ना वैलिड बग नहीं मिल पाएगा जो
आपको डिमोटिवेट कर देगी तो एक टारगेट चूज
करना एक करेक्ट चा टारगेट चूज करना इज
वेरी मच इंपॉर्टेंट और इसके कई सारे
फैक्टर्स हैं अब इसके क्या है कई सारे
फैक्टर्स है सब लोग इधर ध्यान दे लो अभी
सब लोग इधर ध्यान दो एकदम ध्यान से ध्यान
से समझो इस चीज को कि मैं क्या समझा रहा
हूं बहुत ही गोल्डन चीज है जो मैं आपको
बता रहा हूं गाइज बहुत ही डिटेल में बता
रहा हूं मैंने आपको पहले ही बोला था बग
बांटी की जो क्लासेस है डिटेल में
धीरे-धीरे स्लो एंड स्टडी वाली काम होगी
एंड वैसे ही चलेगी अब मान
लो चलो एक ना मैं एग्जांपल एक मैं
एग्जांपल तुम एक एग्जांपल मैं तुम्हारे
सामने रखता हूं देयर इज एन एग्जांपल ठीक
है लेट्स सपोज मेरे पास एक टारगेट
है मेरे पास एक टारगेट है ए बी सी कॉ यह
डोमेन है मैं इसपे बक्स फाइंड करने की सोच
रहा हूं यह टारगेट है ठीक है भैया और एक
और टारगेट
है xyz.com ये दूसरा टारगेट है बट मैं
क्या कर रहा हूं मैं abc.com पे हंट करने
की सोच रहा हूं आई विल हंट ऑन दिस आई विल
हंट ऑन दिस सोच रहा हूं अब मुझे यह जानना
है मुझे यह समझना पड़ेगा कि मैं एक्चुअल
की एक्चुअली हंट किस पे करूं abc.com पे
करूं या xyz.com पे करूं कौन सा टारगेट
मेरे लिए बेस्ट है यह मुझे डिसाइड करना है
एंड इसके बहुत सारे फैक्टर्स है उसको
ध्यान में रखते हुए डिसाइड करना है अब मान
लो मैंने abc.com पे हंट करना शुरू किया
मान लो लेट्स सपोज मैंने इसपे हंट करना
शुरू किया अब इसमें क्या है अब इसमें क्या
है इसमें 5000 हंट इसमें 5000 रिसर्चस
ऑलरेडी हंट कर रहे हैं इसके स्कोप बहुत
लेस है बहुत लेस स्कोप है स्कोप लेस है
ठीक है एंड
इनका इनका ट्रायक टाइम ट्रायक टाइम भी लेस
है मतलब ये जल्दी रिस्पांस भी नहीं देते
हैं थोड़ा लेट रिस्पांस करते हैं रिस्पांस
टाइम जो है इनका थोड़ा सा कम है ठीक है इस
तरीके का मतलब रिस्पांस टाइम ज्यादा है अ
टारगेट ट्रायक टाइम इनका अ मच मोर बहुत
ज्यादा है इनका ठीक है ट्रायक टाइम और एक
टारगेट है हमारा xyz.com यहां पे मान लो
1000 रिसर्चस हैं ठीक है यहां पे बिग
स्कोप है इसमें अब स्कोप क्या है वो भी
मैं बताऊंगा टेंशन नहीं लेनी है बिग स्कोप
है एंड यहां पे लेस ट्राक टाइम है लेस
ट्राक ये सब मैं आपसे डिस्कस करूंगा क्या
है ये सारी चीजें ठीक है लेटस ट्रायक टाइम
है अब मुझे आप बताइए आप अपने मतलब
मेंटालिटी से बताइए अपनी सोच से बताइए आप
abc.com पे हंट करना पसंद करेंगे या
xyz.com पे हंट करना पसंद करेंगे जल्दी
बताइए मुझे चैट में प्लीज लेट मी नो इन द
चैट
एवरीवन
प्लीज एलेना टेक वेलकम ब्रदर प्लीज लेट मी
नो इन द चैट व्हिच टारगेट यू वुड लाइक टू
हंट ऑन abc.com और xyz.com आपके अकॉर्डिंग
कौन सा
होगा एंड आई एम
सी
चलिए सभी के आंसर आने देते
हैं लेट एवरीवन आंसर देन आई विल एक्सप्लेन
एवरीथिंग ओके ओके भाविन इ सेइंग एक्स वाई
जड आदर्श ठाकुर इ एक्सवाई जड ऑर्बिट
एक्सवाई जड एक्सवाई जड ये ऑर्बिट एक्सवाई
जड के तो नाम में भी एक्स वा जड है रोहित
एक्सवाई जड अक्षय एक्सवाई जड ओके ऑफ यू आर
सेइंग एक्स वाई जड राइट बहुत बढ़िया सही
है सही है बिल्कुल सही है एक्स वाई जड
बिल्कुल सही है
लेकिन यह बिल्कुल सही है एकदम परफेक्ट
अब अब मैंने यह सारे फैक्टर्स डाले हैं यह
सारे फैक्टर्स डाल दिए मैंने यहां पर आपके
लिए कुछ फैक्टर्स बना के रखे थे यह सारे
फैक्टर्स जो आपको यहां पे दिख रही है एक
ये सारे पॉइंट्स दिख रहे हैं अब मान लो
लेट्स सपोज इसमें एक्स वाई जड में नो
स्किल्स ऑफ
योर्स एंड ऊपर वाले में ऊपर वाले
में अकॉर्डिंग टू योर
स्किल्स ये एक फैक्टर मैंने ऐड कर दिया
मतलब कि एक्स वाई जड टारगेट में ना जो
वनबिल इन्होंने बोला है फाइंड करने का जिस
तरह का स्कोप डिफाइन करा है जिस तरह की
वलने बिलिटी पे ये रिवर्ड कर रहे हैं ना
वो आपके स्किल सेट्स में है ही नहीं यू
डोंट मास्टर दैट स्किल बट abc.com में
टारगेट जो है इसमें वो स्किल आप मास्टर
करते हो तो यहां पे आपका मेोजी चेंज होना
चाहिए यहां आपका मेथी क्या होना चाहिए
थोड़ा चेंज हो जाना चाहिए अब यहां मेथी
क्या होना चाहिए अब आपको क्या करना चाहिए
आपको एक्स वाई जड को यहां पर छोड़ देना है
बिल्कुल छोड़ देना है अब इसमें भी कुछ
कांट्रडिक्शंस है कुछ कुछ इसमें भी क्या
है कुछ कांट्रडिक्शंस है कुछ इसमें भी
एक्सेप्शन है वो भी मैं बात करूंगा क्या
एक्सेप्शन है क्या कंट्रक्शन है अब यहां
पे आपका टारगेट क्या हो जाना चाहिए
abc.com व्हाई व्हाई बिकॉज़ यू हैव दैट
स्किल्स दैट इज रिक्वायर्ड टू हंट ऑन
abc.com टू हंट ऑन द स्कोप्स ऑफ abc.com
तो ये चेंज ऑफ जो आपका टारगेट हुआ चेंज ऑफ
जो आपका मेथड हुआ जो मेथड चेंज हुआ यही
मेथड जो है ना अलग-अलग टारगेट के लिए
अलग-अलग स्कोप के लिए अलग-अलग अ टाइम
पीरियड के लिए अलग-अलग तरीके से आपको अपना
चेंज करना है बनाना है क्रिएट करना है जिस
दिन आप ये सीख जाएंगे ना कि बग हंटिंग में
मेथड कैसे क्रिएट करते हैं कैसे मेथड बना
के मेथड बना के खुद से हंट करते हैं ना उस
दिन आपको डुप्लीकेट्स मिलने बंद हो जाएंगे
इट्स माय गारंटी नहीं बंद होना तो बताना
मुझे नहीं बंद हो तो बताना उस दिन से ही
डुप्लीकेट्स मिलने बंद हो जाएंगे एंड उस
दिन से तुम्हारे अंदर जो मोटिवेशन जागेगी
ना क्योंकि बाउंट मिलेगी रिवर्ड मिलेगा
स्वैग मिलेगा भैया क्या-क्या मिलेगा पता
ही नहीं मुझे हर कंपनी का अलग-अलग अपना
फंडा है तब तुम्हें समझ में आएगा कि बाप
रे यह तो भाई क्या फील्ड है क्या डोमेन है
क्या शानदार डोमेन है क्या खतरनाक डोमेन
है ये समझ में आ रहा है इतना तो समझ में आ
रहा है है ना सर आई एम ऑलरेडी अ डिफ पेड
डिफ्रॉक्ड चलो अच्छी बात है ये गॉट इट अब
यहां पे ये तो मैंने छोटा सा टारगेट आपको
छोटा सा बताया तरीका छोटा सा एक स्कोप का
और रिसर्चस का अब ट्रैक टाइम का यह जो कुछ
ऑप्शन है व मैंने आपको बताए ठीक है अब मैं
आपको बताऊंगा एक्चुअल चीजें कि कैसे क्या
किस तरीके से करना है किस तरीके से करना
है प्रैक्टिकल आज प्रैक्टिकल पार्ट भी है
थोड़ा सा तो उसको भी हम लाएंगे जल्दी से
जाएंगे ठीक है थोड़ा वेट कीजिए इसको मैं
क्लोज कर देता हूं चलिए अब यहां
पर अब यहां पर हम बात करते हैं कि राइट
टारगेट चूज करने के लिए क्याक जरूरी है
सबसे पहला
स्कोप स्कोप दे देखना है स्कोप क्या होता
है व्हाट इज स्कोप स्कोप का मतलब क्या
होता है मैं आपको वो चीज दिखाता हूं व्हाट
इज स्कोप तो इसके लिए हम बग क्राउड पे
चलेंगे वीी विल गो ऑन अ प्लेटफॉर्म ऑन अ
बग बाउंट प्लेटफॉर्म व्हिच प्रोवाइड्स अ
इंटरकनेक्शन बिटवीन द कंपनीज एंड
सिक्योरिटी रिसर्चस टू हंट हंट ऑन
पर्टिकुलर अ लाइक स्कोप्स और वेबसाइट्स और
ए एप्लीकेशन टीसी तो हम यहां पे आ जाते
हैं b.com पे यहां b.com पे प्रोग्राम्स
पे आप आएंगे तो सारी प्रोग्राम्स यहां पे
लिस्टेड मिल जाएंगे इसमें से हम कोई एक
प्रोग्राम को उठा लेते हैं कोई से भी एक
प्रोग्राम उठा लेते हैं जैसे हब स्पॉट चलो
इसको उठा लिया हब स्पॉट को हमने उठा लिया
यह हमने पिक कर लिया हब स्पॉट वी पिड हब
स्टॉप ट्रैक टाइम क्या होता है वो भी मैं
बताऊंगा जस्ट वेट रूट जी आप तो रूट है यू
हैव अ यू आईडी ऑफ जीरो यू हैव फुल कंट्रोल
थोड़ा सा कंट्रोल आपने पे अपने ऊपर भी
कीजिए और मैं आपको बताऊंगा ट्रैक टाइम
क्या होता है ठीक
है चलिए अब यहां पे जब आप इस पर्टिकुलर
प्रोग्राम पे आते हैं हब हब स्पॉट के ठीक
है हब स्पॉट के पर्टिकुलर प्रोग्राम पे
आते हैं तो जब आप नीचे आएंगे यहां पे तो
यहां पे आपको स्कोप एंड रिवार्ड्स का
ऑप्शन मिलेगा टीचस अबाउट वनबिल देखो सब
बताऊंगा लेकिन अगर हरबड़ा होगे तो मैं भी
हर बड़ी में तुम्हें हरबड़ा के बताऊंगा तो
तुम्हें समझ नहीं आएगा उतना फास्ट में
जाऊंगा तो म नहीं आ धीरे-धीरे चलो एकदम
लाइन वाइज चलो आराम से चलो कोई हड़बड़ी
नहीं है सब चीजें ना बेसिक से जानो
क्योंकि ये जान जाओगे ना ये जो चीजें मैं
बता रहा हूं ना ये बे यही बेस्ट कांसेप्ट
है यही तो है यार मेन फैक्टर इसी को तो
तुम नहीं पकड़ पाओगे ना तो तुम्हें वही
तुम बाकी लोगों से फिर अलग नहीं हो पाओगे
मैं सच बता रहा हूं अब मुझे एक बात बताओ
यार एक क्वेश्चन है तुमसे यहां पे अभी 114
लोग लाइव है कितने लोग लाइव हैं चलो 114
लोग लाइव है मान लो हैं मान लो इस वीडियो
को लास्ट वाली प्रीवियस हमारी जो सेशन हुई
थी पता है उसको कितने लोगों ने अभी देख
लिया 3500 लोगों ने देख लिया मान लो 5000
लोगों ने देख लिया मान लो आने वाले टाइम
में अब उन 5000 लोगों को सेम चीजें पता है
अगर वो सेम तरीके से सब कुछ करेंगे तो
ओबवियसली उन पांच 5000 में से अलग कौन
होगा कोई नहीं होगा सबको डुप्लीकेट्स
मिलेंगे डूप्स मिलेंगे सब सबका वही सेम
चीज रहेगा तो फिर क्या डिफरेंट है भाई
डिफरेंस तो है ही नहीं आपके में तो बट ये
मेथड समझ लोगे ना तो यू विल बी डिफरेंट
देन अदर्स तो आपका मेथड अलग होगा आपके
आपका जो ये मतलब वे ऑफ अप्रोच जो है वो
अलग होगा एंड देन यू विल फाइंड वैलिड बग्स
मोर ऑफेन देन अदर्स गॉट
इट गॉट इट चलो अब यहां पे रिवार्ड्स एंड
स्कोप यह आपको दिख रहा होगा यही है स्कोप
यही है स्कोप मतलब कि इस पर्टिकुलर
प्रोग्राम ने आपको बताया है कि यह
पर्टिकुलर वेबसाइट्स हैं यह पर्टिकुलर
डोमेंस हैं या यह पर्टिकुलर वाइड कार्ड
डोमेंस है या सब डोमेन जिनके सारे सब
डोमेन सारी चीज इंक्लूडेड होते हैं इन
वेबसाइट्स पे या एंड एप्लीकेशन पे आप हंट
कर सकते हैं आप उसपे बाउंट ले सकते हैं
अगर आपको वैलिड बग मिलता है तो या रिवॉर्ड
ले सकते हैं हल ऑफ फेम लिख सकते हैं आप उन
पे बग्स फाइंड कर सकते हैं वनबिल फाइंड कर
सकते हैं स्कोप का मतलब सीधा यही होता है
बट ये बहुत बड़ा इंपॉर्टेंट रोल प्ले करता
है जब मैंने बहुत पहले जब मैं हंट करता था
तो क्या हुआ था कि अ शफाई प्रोग्राम का
नाम आपने सुना होगा शफाई पे मैंने एक
वनबिल फाइंड की थी ठीक है मैं बहुत खुश हो
गया था क्योंकि वो लेबिलिटी जो थी ना वो
काफी अच्छी थी मतलब ठीक थी p3 p3 कैटेगरी
की ऑलमोस्ट रही होगी या p4 ही रही होगी
चलो लो ही था बट स्टिल वैलिड था तो मुझे
बहुत मजा आया था मैंने रिपोर्ट रिपोर्ट कर
दिया सब कुछ ठीक है मुझे जब रिप्लाई आता
है तो उन्होंने कहा उन्होंने कहा कि ये जो
है हमारा ये आउट ऑफ स्कोप आपका जो जो
पार्ट है ना आपका बक बाउंडी प्रोग्राम का
इसमें ये आउट ऑफ स्कोप है ये पर्टिकुलर
चीज तो आपका ये चीज एप्लीकेबल ही नहीं
होता है नॉट एप्लीकेबल है तो वैलिड है बट
नॉट एप्लीकेबल है बिकॉज दैट वाज आउट ऑफ
स्कोप तो उस टाइम मुझे उतना आईडिया नहीं
होता था कि भैया इन स्कोप आउट स्कोप को
इतना ज्यादा ध्यान देना है इतना ज्यादा उस
परे फोकस करना है मैं सोचा लो यार कोई बात
नहीं शफाई या कहीं जो जो जो कुछ मिल जाए
रिपोर्ट मार दो आज के टाइम में जो
बिगिनर्स है ना ये काम करते हैं मैंने
देखा है मेरे बहुत सारे स्टूडेंट्स ने भी
जब मुझे बताया कि मैंने ये किया वो किया
ये फाइंड किया तो मैंने देखा है उनकी जो
मिस्टेक होती है कि क्या होती है कि एज अ
बिगनर उनकी गलती नहीं है वो बिगनर के तौर
पे हर कोई करता है तो वो कुछ भी रिपोर्ट
कर देते हैं मतलब एक्चुअल में ना हमें
आईडिया नहीं होता कि ये एक्चुअल वैलिड
होगी कि नहीं होगी ये बग होगी भी कि नहीं
होगी कुछ भी सामने थोड़ा अटपटा दिखता आया
थोड़ा अटपटा अ प्रिंट होता आउटपुट में आ
गया हमें लगता है अरे बग है कई बार तो यार
जैसे मान लो robot.txt है उसको ही लोग बग
समझ लेते हैं भाई इसकी मैं आउटपुट में गजब
गजब की चीजें आ रही है तो
ये हो सकता है ये बग होगा कई बार तो साइट
मैप भैया साइ
वो सारे इन स्कोप है एंड उस पे आप हंट कर
सकते हैं जैसे इन्होंने एक h
api.ai क पे hubspot.com पे ह हंट कर सकते
हैं hubspot.com
ए एप्लीकेशन है अ उस पे कर सकते हैं आप बग
फाइंड कर सकते हैं एंड एक ह स्पॉट का आईओ
एप्लीकेशन है उस पे आप हंट कर सकते हैं
इसी के साथ-साथ नीचे में यहां पे आउट
स्कोप डोमेंस भी है इन्होंने मेंशन कर रखा
है मतलब क्या है गाइस यहां पे ये जो
डोमेंस है ना आपको अगर इस पे कोई वनबिल
मिलती है चाहे वो रिमोट कोड एग्जीक्यूशन
क्यों ना हो ये कंपनी के ऊपर डिपेंड करता
है कि वो उसको एक्सेप्ट करेगी एज अ वैलिड
बग या नहीं या उसको नॉट एप्लीकेबल या फिर
उसको जो भी है उसको रिजेक्ट कर देगी ये
कंपनी के ऊपर है हां अब होता क्या है ना
जैसे मान लो कि कोई एक बाउंट कोई एक ये
स्कोप है इन आउट ऑफ स्कोप आइटम है कोई मान
लो ठीक है अब इसमें जैसे ब्लॉकड
hubspot.com है अब मान लो इस पर्टिकुलर
डोमेन पे तुमने कोई बहुत क्रिटिकल वलने
बिलिटी फाइंड कर ली बहुत क्रिटिकल आरसी
फाइंड कर लिया कमांड इंजेक्शन टाइप मतलब
या एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन फाइंड कर लिया एंड
कंपनी को तुमने फिर भी रिपोर्ट कर दिया तो
कंपनी के ऊपर टोटली डिपेंड करता है कि वो
उस बग को नॉर्मली ठीक कर ले अपना और आपको
कोई रिवॉर्ड ना दे और आपको बोले कि नहीं
नहीं है बट और यह भी हो सकता है कि कंपनी
जेनरिसिटी के साथ आपको उसको एक्सेप्ट करे
कि ये तो बहुत क्रिटिकल बग है इतनी बड़ी
इतनी क्रिटिकल बग तो यार हमने एक्सपेक्ट
नहीं कर रहा था एंड उसको आपको रिवॉर्ड दे
आपको सम्मानित किया जाए बाउंट भी दे दे तो
ये उनके हाथ में है लेकिन आउट ऑफ स्कोप
डोमेंस को आपको यूजुअली टच नहीं करना है
टाइम वेस्ट नहीं करना है यह बात ध्यान में
रखना है तो इन सारे डोमेंस पे आपको हंट
नहीं करने का होता है और इनमें अगर कोई
आपको कुछ मिलता भी है तो अगर आप रिपोर्ट
करो ना करो ना करो तो ज्यादा बेटर है टाइम
क्यों वेस्ट करना राइट उसके बाद आप नीचे
आओगे तो यहां पे आपको एक फोकस एरिया दिखता
है फोकस एरिया का मतलब है इन चीजों पे
आपको फोकस करना है फोकस इन चीजों को ये
ज्यादा वैल्यूज दे रहे हैं किन पे
एक्सेसेस पे क्रॉस सेट स्क्रिप्टिंग को यह
ज्यादा वैल्यू दे रहे हैं ऑथेंटिकेशन एंड
ऑथराइजेशन फ्लज जो है उनको ज्यादा वैल्यू
दे रहे हैं अब आपको पता नहीं है ना
ऑथेंटिकेशन ऑथराइजेशन फ्लॉस क्या होते हैं
यह तो आपको समझ में नहीं आ रहा होगा
ऑथेंटिकेशन ऑथराइजेशन क्या होता होगा अगर
आप पीछे जाएंगे यहां पे तो आपको यहां पर
दिखेगा यह आपको यहां पर दिखेगा यह देखो
नीचे आओगे ओस टॉप 10 में तो आपको यहां
दिखेगा ऑथेंटिकेशन का ऑथराइजेशन का जो
लिस्ट है वो आपको दिख जाएगा एंड इस लिस्ट
में आपको समझ में आ जाएगा कि अच्छा ये
वाली ऑथेंटिकेशन है अरे ये वाली इस
कैटेगरी में ये ये लेबिलिटी आ जाते हैं तो
इसलिए ओस टॉप 10 का जानना बहुत जरूरी है
ठीक है मैं अभी उस पे भी आऊंगा उसके बाद
सर्वर साइड कोड एजुकेशन बक्स जो है उस पे
ये फोकस कर रहे हैं सेंसिटिव डाटा
एक्सपोजर पे फोकस कर रहे हैं एंड
पर्टिकुलर क्लेवर वनबिल और यूनिक इश्यूज
दैट डू नॉट फॉल इन टू एक्सप्लिसिट कैटेगरी
उन पे भी ये फोकस करवा रहे हैं ठीक है कुछ
यहां पे रूल्स है इन्होंने रूल्स डिफाइन
करा अब देखो यार रूल्स देखना जरूरी है अब
क्या क्या होता है ना रूल्स में उन्होंने
लिखा रहता है कि डॉस अटैक आप नहीं कर सकते
यू कांट डू एनी डॉस अटैक और उसपे लोग डॉस
अटैक कर कर के और बोलते हैं कि भैया ये
लेबिलिटी है ये लेबिलिटी एप्लीकेशन लेवल
डॉस अटैक चलता है बट यूजुअल आप डॉस अटैक
कर रहे हो वैसे करके कि हां भैया डॉस अटैक
हमने कर दिया हम उसको जाके दिखा देते हैं
उनको कोई हार्म नहीं हो रहा कोई इंपैक्ट
नहीं हो रहा है तो कोई फायदा नहीं है
उसमें टाइम वेस्ट नहीं करना है मैं एक ही
चीज बोलूंगा भैया ऐसी वनबिल ऐसा हंटिंग
ऐसा वलने बिलिटी आपको रिपोर्ट करना होता
है ना उसका इंपैक्ट दिखे सामने वाले को कि
ये वलने बिलिटी मेरे कंपनी के ऊपर क्या
इंपैक्ट डाल सकती है व्हाट इंपैक्ट इट कैन
पुट ऑन आवर कंपनी ये मेन मैटर करता है ये
मेन आपका मोटिव होना चाहिए कि इंपैक्टफुल
वनबिल रिपोर्ट करें ना कि कुछ भी रिपोर्ट
कर दे राइट ऑलवेज रिमेंबर दिस
चलिए ये तो हो गई अब आप इन स्कोप में एक
चीज देख रहे होंगे क्या देख रहे होंगे गाइ
ये स्टार डॉट लगा हुआ है ये किस किसी को
पता है ये स्टार का मतलब क्या होता है एनी
वन नो प्लीज लेट मी नो किसी को पता है
क्या स्टार का मतलब क्या होता है प्लीज
लेट मी
नो काइंडली लेट मी
नो जल्दी बताइए स्टार का मतलब क्या होता
है कितने लोगों को पता है हाउ मेनी ऑफ यू
ऑलरेडी नोइंग व्ट दिस स्टार
मींस चलिए बताइए जल्दी जल्दी बताइए जल्दी
बताइए जल्दी लेट मी नो फास्ट गा इतना टाइम
नहीं है जल्दी बताइए स्टार का मतलब क्या
होता है किसको पता है इंपॉर्टेंट चलो ठीक
है और
कुछ डोंट नो डोंट नो ल सब डोमेंस
बढ़िया बढ़िया चलिए
जिनको जिनको बहुत पता था टेक्निकली
उन्होंने वाइल्ड काड बोला है जिनको पता था
उन्होंने बोला सारे सब डोमेंस और जिनको
नहीं पता था उन्होंने बोला अ जिनको थोड़ा
मतलब लग रहा था कि कुछ हो सकता है
इंपॉर्टेंट बोला जिनको बिल्कुल नहीं पता
था उन्होंने बोला नहीं पता है वेरी गुड
नहीं पता होना इज नॉट अ बैड थिंग आपकी
लर्निंग की प्रोसेस में बहुत सारी चीजें
बहुत सारी चीजें नहीं पता होती है इनफैक्ट
मुझे भी सारी चीजें नहीं पता होती है बट
आपको सीखना होता है आप सीखो ग तो ही पता
चलेगा राइट अब इसका मतलब ये होता है ना
गाइ कि ये एक वाइल्ड कार्ड एंट्री को शो
करता है एक वाइल्ड कार्ड डोमेन को शो करता
है वाइल्ड कार्ड डोमेन का मतलब सिंपल सा
फंडा यह समझो कि हब
ap.com ठीक है ह
ap.com के जितने भी सब डोमस
है जो इसके आगे में लगेंगे वह सब इसमें
इंक्लूडेड है इसका एग्जांपल मैं आपको दिखा
देता हूं बता देता हूं जैसे मान लो मेरा
डोमेन है हमारी खुद की डोमेन ले लो
fix.com हमारी खुद की वेबसाइट ले लेते हैं
ठीक है मान लो de.com दिस इज द डोमेन तो
यह एक सिंगल डोमेन मेन हो गया अब मैं इसके
पीछे अगर मैं यहां st.don क लगा देता हूं
इसका मतलब है कि मैं de.com के साथ-साथ
इसके जितने सब डोमेन है मैं सबको इंक्लूड
कर रहा हूं आई एम इंक्लूडिंग एवरी सब
डोमेन इन दिस सब डोमेन का मतलब क्या है जो
डोमेन का ही एक पार्ट है डोमेन का ही एक
पार्ट है दैट इज नोन एज सब
डोमेन ठीक है अब इसका एग्जांपल भी मैं
समझा देता हूं आपको अपने ही वेबसाइट से
मैं समझाता हूं जैसे ये de.com है ये
डोमेन है एक दिस इज अ
डोमेन ठीक है वेबसाइट जो आप बोलते हो
यूजुअली अब इसी पे अगर हम अकेडमी पे क्लिक
करेंगे इस वाले ऑप्शन पे तो जैसे ही
अकेडमी प क्लिक करेंगे यहां पे एक और
वेबसाइट खुल जाएगी एंड इस वेबसाइट का जो
यूआरएल है आप ऊपर देखिए
academy.com दिस इज सब डोमेन तो यहां पे
मैं इसको कॉपी कर लेता हूं यह सब डोमेन
हमारा कौन सा हो गया एडमी ड . कॉ
प्रोटोकॉल हटा देता हूं फिलहाल ये हमारा
सब डोमेन हो गया . कॉ का ठीक है ये हमारा
सब डोमेन हो गया अब यहां पे मैं एक और सब
डोमेन मेरा हो सकता है
help.com
या फिर मेरा एक और सब डोमेन हो सकता है
बॉड de.com
इस तरीके से डोमेन और सब डोमेन तो आपको
पता ही होगा डोमेन हमारी di.com ये एक
वेबसाइट हो गई जहां बहुत सारे वेब पेजेस
को मिला के एक वेबसाइट बनती हैट इज नोन एज
यहां पे यह डोमेन फोनिक्स इ डोमेन यह एक
इसका एक्सटेंशन हो गया com.net .
org.in ये एक्सटेंशंस हो गई एंड यह पूरी
मिला के आपकी वेबसाइट हो जाती है पूरी
वेबसाइट हो गई इ पर्टिकुलर आपका डेफॉक्स
जो है यह आपका डोमेन हो गया ठीक है de.com
इज अ टी एलडी डोमेन टी एलडी टॉप लेवल
डोमेन ठीक है कनेट ये सब टॉप लेवल डोमेन
के कैटेगरी में आते हैं तो दीज आर डोमेन
अब इसी का पार्ट जो है वो सब डोमेन हो गया
तो तो अब जो सब डोमेन होता है गाइ वो
वेबसाइट के ही
डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
जब आप यहां
पर रट
गोस बक जब आप यहां पर स्टार देख रहे इसका
मतलब है ह एआई कॉ के जितने भी सब डोमेन से
सब आप टेस्ट कर सकते हैं सब पर आप बग्स
वलन बिलिटी फाइंड कर सकते हैं यू कैन हंट
ऑन एनी ऑफ द सब डोमन एंड दे विल
रिकॉग्नाइज ट इफट लेबिलिटी या बग इ वैलिड
कट चलो यह समझ में आ गया अब यह तो आ गई
आपकी सब डोमेंस की डोमेंस की बात इन इन
स्कोप आउट स्कोप की बात आपको समझ में आ गई
सारी चीज आपको क्लियर हो गई राइट तो स्कोप
अब बात करते हैं लार्ज वर्सेस स्मॉल अब
देखो जितना बड़ा स्कोप होगा ना उतने
ज्यादा चांसेस होंगे कि आपको लो हैंगिंग
बग्स मिलने के लो हैंगिंग बग्स मतलब छोटे
मोटे बट इंपैक्टफुल बग्स छोटे मोटे बट
इंपैक्टफुल बग उसमें ज्यादा चांसेस होंगे
आपको मिलने के जितना बड़ा स्कोप होगा मान
लो कोई एक कोई एक वेबसाइट है जैसे अ लेट्स
सपोज facebook.com अ facebook.com इज अ
वेरी ह्यूज अ हैज अ वेरी ह्यूज स्कोप
facebook.com के पास जितने डोमस है सब
डोमस है सब इंक्लूडेड है कैसे मैं दिखा
देता हूं
अब यहां पे स्कोप देखो इनकी जस्ट सी द
स्कोप तुम देख रहे हो यहां पे पूरी
facebook.co अब नीचे जब आओगे तो तुम्हें
मैसेंजर के
कैसे आप उनको अप्रोच करोगे किस तरीके से
करोगे सब देखेंगे तो आपको समझ में आने
लगेगा हर एक चीज एक दूसरे से कनेक्टेड है
हर एक चीज एक दूसरे से कनेक्ट होके रहेगी
याद रखना ऐसे ही रेगुलर रहोगे तो बहुत मजा
आएगा जैसे ही रेगुलेरिटी खत्म हुई इस
क्लास के अंदर आपका इंटरेस्ट खत्म हो
जाएगा और आप मेरे साथ कोप अप नहीं कर
पाओगे एंड आपने अगर कोप अप करना बंद कर
दिया तो आप फिर बग हंटर फिर ऐसे भाई ऐसे
फ्री में तो नहीं बन पाओगे यार मतलब जो
मैं आपको नॉलेज दे रहा हूं वो बहुत टॉप
नॉज दे रहा हूं सच बता रहा हूं मैं मतलब
एकदम बेसिक से बता रहा हूं भैया एकदम
बिगनर लेवल से बहुत कुछ बताऊंगा तो अभी
जानते हो खजाना है भाई अनलिमिटेड नॉलेज है
उसमें से निकाल निकाल के क्यूरेट करके
आपको बताया जा रहा है क्योंकि नॉलेज की
कोई इसमें लिमिटेशन नहीं है वर्क बाउटी
में ठीक है
गट चलो तो ये लार्ज स्कोप वाले जो आपके
प्रोग्राम है उनको चूज करो बट कभी-कभी
स्मॉल स्कोप प्रोग्राम को भी चूज कर सकते
हो क्योंकि सब लोग क्या सोचते हैं लार्ज
स्को प्रोग्राम में ज्यादा आपको लो
हैंगिंग फ्रूट्स मिलेंगे और स्मॉल को कई
बार लोग नेगलेक्ट कर देते हैं उस टाइम में
आपका क्या है एक बनता है एक बार स्मॉल
वाले प्रोग्राम्स प भी हंट करना एक बार
बनता है जस्ट गिव इट अ ट्राई ट्राई
करो पहली चीज अब बात करते हैं यहां पे
रिवर्ड या
बाउंटीज या बाउंट अब देखो जैसे मैं यहां
पे मैं यहां पे चलता हूं ब ब बक राउड पे
यहां पे अब यहां पे तुम्हें दिखेंगे कुछ
प्रोग्राम्स जो है ना वो आपको बाउंट दे
रहे हैं पैसे दे रहे हैं डॉलर में कुछ
प्रोग्राम आप को बाउंट नहीं दे रहे दे आर
नॉट गिविंग एनी बाउंट दे आर गिविंग जस्ट
पॉइंट्स जैसे ऊपर चलते हैं यहां पे कुछ
पॉइंट वाले अगर हमें मिल जाते हैं तो
अच्छी बात है जैसे ये क्लास डोजो दिस
लेबिलिटी प्रोग्राम इज गिविंग व्हाट इज
गिविंग पॉइंट्स टू $100 पॉइंट्स भी दे रहे
हैं डॉलर भी दे रहे हैं ऐसे प्रोग्राम
जिसमें सिर्फ पॉइंट मिल रहे
हो बाउंट नहीं मिल रही बाउंट मिल भी रही
हो तो अच्छी बात है बट अगर सिर्फ पॉइंट
वाले आपको मिल रहे हैं
[संगीत]
दैट्ची आ जाओ यहां पे कोई एक देख लेते
हैं नीचे आ जाते
हैं जैसे ये ये एक प्रोग्राम है पैंथन
पैंथन इसमें पॉइंट से $500 तक मिल रहा है
ओनली पॉइंट से स्टार्ट होंगे ओनली $500
इसमें नीचे आओ यहां पे नीचे आओ यहां पे
नीचे आओ यहां पे यहां पे नीचे आओगे यहां
पे तो ऐसे प्रोग्राम इसमें आपको ना नीचे
जब आओगे यहां पे जब नीचे आओगे यहां पे
बाउंट रिवार्ड्स पॉइंट में यहां पे तो
तुम्हें दिख रहे होंगे कि p4 कैटेगरी के
लिए इनके पी फ कैटेगरी में 0 से लेके $75
तक आपको बाउंट मिल रही है यानी आपको 00
में मिल जाता पॉइंट्स भी मिल सकते हैं ऐसे
प्रोग्राम्स को ऐसे जो
आपके बग बाउंट प्रोग्राम्स है उन पे हंट
कर सकते हो क्योंकि ऐसे प्रोग्राम्स में
रिसर्चर जो होते हैं ना थोड़ा ज्यादा
इंटरेस्टेड नहीं जो बड़े-बड़े रिसर्चर
रिसर्चस नहीं जो बहुत बड़े लेवल पे है
रिसर्चस ऐसे प्रोग्राम्स में ज्यादा
इंटरेस्ट नहीं लेते घुस तो जाते हैं अपनी
हंटिंग करते भी हैं बट बहुत ज्यादा
कंसिस्टेंट नहीं रहते एंड उसकी वजह से
बहुत सारे ऐसी लेबिलिटी है जो छूट जाती है
जो इनमें रह जाती है स्पेशली p3 p4
कैटेगरी की क्योंकि ये p3 और p4 कैटेगरी
में रो लर से स्टार्ट करते हैं तो आपको
यहां पे चांसेस हैं कि p3 और p4 कैटेगरी
के जो वले एबिलिटीज हैं वो आपको यहां पे
वैलिड मिलने के चांसेस ज्यादा होते हैं तो
ऐसे प्रोग्राम्स में घुस जाना है यू हैव
टू एंटर इन दिस टाइप ऑफ प्रोग्राम्स जहां
पर आपको पैसे ज्यादा नहीं मिल रहे हो ठीक
है क्योंकि ऐसे में बड़े-बड़े जो हंटर्स
होते हैं वो नहीं घुसते हैं उनको बाउंट से
मतलब होती है दे नो कि वो बाउंट ले सकते
हैं तो क्यों घुस जिसमें बाउंट मिल नहीं
रही है क्यों अपना टाइम खोटा करेंगे क्यों
अपना टाइम वेस्ट करेंगे राइट तो ये एक
आपका मेथड होना चाहिए ये एक माइंड सेट
होना चाहिए कि आप घुसो किसमें रिवॉर्ड
बाउंट देख के कि अगर आप इनिशियल लेवल पे
स्टार्ट कर रहे हो डोंट सी एनी बाउंट
अमाउंट आपको बाउंट मिल रही है नहीं मुझे
मतलब नहीं है हॉल ऑफ फेम है स्वैग भी है
या सिर्फ पॉइंट मिल रहा है पहले उसमें
घुसो ज्यादा चांसेस उसमें होंगे आपके बग
फाइंड करने के एक वैलिड बग फाइंड करने
के
चलो हां व्हाट इज p1 प2 p3 p4 ये एक हरकी
है बग
के मतलब
व है ठीक है p1 देर इज p1 p2 p3 p4 p4 ऐसा
तो p1 जो है इसको आप मोस्ट क्रिटिकल बोल
सकते
हो इसको सॉरी इसको आप मोस्ट क्रिटिकल बोल
सकते हो ऐसी वनबिल इस कैटेगरी में फॉल
करती है हाई सीवियरिंग वनबिल में आप इसको
कंसीडर कर सकते हो p2 को आप क्या कर सकते
हो इसमें मोर क्रिटिकल बोल लो ये हाई
सीविरियस हाई सीवियर बोल
लो p3 को आप मीडियम बोल लो मीडियम
सीवियरिंग वाली p4 को आप लो बोल लो ऐसा अब
यह बग क्राउड का अपना एक अ मतलब एक इसको
क्या बोल सकते हैं अपना एक लाइक तरीका है
वनबिल को क्लासिफाई करने का कि इन्होंने
p1 p2 p3 p4 ऐसे डिनोट करा है ठीक है वैसे
ही अगर तुम हैकर वन पे जाओगे इस तरीके से
हैकर वन पे इस तरीके से जाओगे हैकर वन पे
तो इनका क्या होता हाई क्रिटिकल हाई ऐसे
करके ये उसमें कर जैसे तुम चलो यहां पे
एक्टिविटी प चलते हैं यहां पे एक्टिविटी प
चलते हैं यहां प ओपन करते हैं कोई एक
रिपोर्ट को ओपन कर लेते हैं जैसे एक
रिपोर्ट ओपन हुआ है ठीक है तो यहां पे
तुम्हें सीवियरिंग लो की ठीक है ये लो
सीवियरिंग तो ये हाई लो क्रिटिकल मीडियम
इसमें ये डील करते हैं ठीक है तो ये बग
बाउंट प्लेटफॉर्म्स का अपना जो है ना वो
मापदंड है जिस पर ये डिफाइन करते हैं p1
p2 p3 4 ठीक है बस तो बस आपको चारों कैटे
में से कोई से भी मिलना चाहिए ये मतलब
नहीं है p1 के लिए खोजो प2 नहीं भाई पहले
तो p4 से ही शुरू करनी है पहले तो यार एक
वैलिड बग मिल जाए उसम कुछ ना मिले उससे
शुरू करना है बस मेरी बात मानो बस और कुछ
नहीं तो यह इतना समझ में आ रहा है एवरीवन
गेटिंग एवरीवन गेटिंग व्ट आईम अभी तक समझ
में आया अभी तो बहुत कुछ आना बाकी है भाई
वेट करो इतना समझ में आया क्या व्ट आई एम
सेइंग जो भी आपको समझाने की कोशिश कर रहा
हूं कैसा लग रहा है मजा आ रहा है बताइए
जरा मुझे जरा बताइए यार आपके भी कुछ
रिव्यूज लेने जरूरी है भैया बताइए मुझे
कैसा लग रहा
है
ओके
बढ़िया
ग्रेट एआई वर्सेस बग बाउंट फ्यूचर कुछ
नहीं करेगा एई टेंशन मत लो आराम से सीखो
यार रीड कमेंट टू सर कमेंट्स बहुत सारे आ
रहे हैं तो यार पूरे कमेंट्स नहीं पढ़
सकता मैं मैं फोकस कर रहा हूं ट्रेनिंग पे
एंड जो भी आपके डाउट सेशन होंगे मैंने
आपको पहले ही बताया डाउट सेशंस आपके एंड्र
एप्लीकेशन हमारा रोनिस अकेडमी है उसमें
आपको मोस्टली संडे को ही होगा इस संडे
नहीं हुआ है आई नो बट मोस्टली जो नेक्स्ट
संडे है उनसे आपके होंगे आपको नोटिफिकेशन
आ जाएगी और वो कोर्स जॉइन कर लीजिएगा फ्री
वाला उसमें आपको नोटिफिकेशन मिल जाएगी ठीक
है स्पर्स अग्रवाल वेट करो इंतजार करो यार
हैंड्स ऑन होगा सब होगा टेंशन मत लो पहले
यार बेसिक तो समझो यार यही तो दिक्कत है
देखो यही तो प्रॉब्लम है आप लोगों की
बेसिक नहीं समझते आप आप सीधा चाहते
प्रैक्टिकल क्यों भाई प्रैक्टिकल क्यों
आपको बेसिक नहीं समझ में आएगा प्रैक्टिकल
चाहिए आपको बताओ मैं सच बता रहा हूं मैं
प्रैक्टिकल करके एक सप्ताह में बग बाउंट
की क्लास खत्म कर दूंगा क्या फायदा हुआ
सीखो कुछ आप सीखो ग कुछ मुझे बताओ आप ही
से पूछता हूं लेट मी नो मतलब आप क्या
चाहते हो कि मैं प्रैक्टिकल करके सिर्फ
ओनली हवा में बातें करके हवा में
प्रैक्टिकल दिखा के खत्म कर दूं एक सप्ताह
10 दिन में या मैं इसको महीने भर चलाऊं
पूरा मतलब लॉन्ग ड्यूरेशन के लिए और हर एक
चीज को फोकस करके चलू जिससे आप एक डिफरेंट
बग हंटर बनोगे ऐसे नहीं कि ये ऐसे ही भीड़
में चल रहा है वैसा वो वाली काम नहीं करनी
यार प्लीज वो काम करोगे क्या फायदा फिर
हुआ फिर कैसे कह पाओगे मैं कैसे बोलूंगा
यार कि तुमने मेरे स्ट्रीम से कुछ सीखा है
फिर मेरे को भी तो थोड़ा सा प्राउड करने
का वो मौका दो यार कम से कम वो तो दो यार
एटलीस्ट व मौका तो वो म नो ठीक है तो यह
एक आपको पता चल गया स्कोप का आपको पता चल
गया रिवर्ड बाउंट का ठीक है अब पब्लिक
वर्सेस प्राइवेट प्रोग्राम की बात कर लेते
हैं ठीक है पहले उसके बा ट्रैक टीम प आते
हैं पब्लिक वर्सेस प्राइवेट प्रोग्राम का
मतलब क्या होता है यह समझते हैं अब यह जो
प्रोग्राम्स आपको लिस्टेड दिख रहे हैं यह
बक क्राउड पे दिख रहे हैं या फिर यहां पे
हैकर वन पे चलो हैक्टिविटी पे डायरेक्टरी
पे चलो हैकर वन के ये डायरेक्ट्रीएंट्री
फाइंड कर सकते हो और एक होता है प्राइवेट
प्रोग्राम क्या होता है प्राइवेट
प्रोग्राम जैसे कि यहां पे मैं मैंने जब
बक क्राउड मैं थोड़ा ब्राउंड में जब थोड़ा
बहुत हंट कर रहा था तो मुझे भी प्राइवेट
प्रोग्राम्स के इन्विटेशंस आए थे तो मैंने
कुछ इन्विटेशंस एक्सेप्ट किए थे जैसे
एक्सेप्टेड इन्वाइट्स में आपको दिख रहा
होगा यहां पे ठीक है तो मैं इस पे जाता
हूं तो मुझे किसके आए थे बेटर हेल्प के आए
थे कन्वर्ट किट के आए थे ये दो मुझे आए
हुए थे प्राइवेट प्रोग्राम की बट मैंने
जैसा कि आपको बताया मैं कंसिस्टेंटली नहीं
कर पाता ड्यू टू टाइम इश्यूज क्योंकि मेरे
को एक चीज नहीं करनी है मेरे को मल्टीपल
चीजें करनी होती है कंपनी भी चलानी है
कंपनी के भी बारे में भी सोचना है कंपनी
को भी एक्सपेंड करने के बारे में सोचना है
उसकी भी बहुत सारी चीजें होती हैं टीम को
मैनेज करना है बहुत सारी चीजें होती है
ट्रेनिंग होती हैं कोर्सेस होती हैं
youtube0 नहीं कर पाता इस वजह से
इन्विटेशंस दो आ गए थे बट फिर भी स्टिल तो
आपको इस तरह से जो इन्विटेशन आ रहे हैं ना
कहीं से कोई कंपनी आपको पर्टिकुलर इनवाइट
कर रही है एक बाउंट बग बाउंट प्रोग्राम
में वो प्राइवेट प्रोग्राम हो गया अब उस
प्राइवेट प्रोग्राम में नाना चांसेस आर
वेरी हाई कि आपको एक वैलिड बग मिलेगा और
उसके आपके अच्छे खासे आपको बाउंट मिल जाते
हैं ये प्राइवेट प्रोग्राम का एक बेनिफिट
है बट प्राइवेट प्रोग्राम जनरली ऐसा नहीं
होता कि तुरंत आपको एक प्राइवेट प्रोग्राम
दो मिनट में मिल जाएगा नहीं आपको पहले
पब्लिक प्रोग्राम्स पे हंट करना है चाहे
आप डुप्लीकेट्स फाइंड करो नॉट एप्लीकेबल
फाइंड करो या कुछ भी फाइंड करो फाइंड करते
जाओ करते जाओ टाइम स्पेंड करो उस
प्लेटफॉर्म पे जब तुम टाइम स्पेंड करोगे
बग्स फाइंड करना शुरू कर दोगे या भले
डुप्लीकेट्स ही मिल रहे हैं यार
इंफॉर्मेशन ही मिल रहे हैं जब उनको लगेगा
ना कि नाउ यू आर गुड टू गो फॉर प्राइवेट
प्रोग्राम्स तो ऑटोमेटिक तुम्हारे पास
प्राइवेट प्रोग्राम्स के टेशन आने शुरू हो
जाएंगे और अगर तुमने एक दो कहीं वैलिड बग
रिपोर्ट कर दिया मान लो तब तो 100% आते
हैं बट वैलिड बग रिपोर्ट कर दोगे तो
प्राइवेट प्रोग्राम के तुम्हारे पास लाइन
लग जाएंगी झड़ यां लग जाएंगी प्राइवेट
प्रोग्राम्स की इतने सारे आएंगे ना कि तुम
तुम समझ नहीं पाओगे कि किसको एक्सेप्ट
करूं किस पे हंट करूं क्या करूं बहुत सारी
आती है तो एक वैलिड बग फाइंड करना है और
वैलिड बग फाइंड करने के पहले डुप्लीकेट्स
नॉट एप्लीकेबल इंफॉर्मेशन ये आने ही आने
हैं और आने भी चाहिए बट उसको हम मिनिमाइज
करेंगे अपने मेथड से कि बाकी लोगों को अगर
डुप्लीकेट्स मिल रहे हैं एक हफ्ते तक
डुप्लीकेट्स मिल रहे हैं तो आपको 5 दिन तक
ही मिले न दिन तक ही मिले कुछ लोगों को दो
दिन तक मिले ऐसा माइंडसेट समझ रहे हो ना
मैं क्या बोलना चाह रहा हूं आर यू गेटिंग
व्हाट आई वांट टू से और देखो जितने लोग
आते हो कंटिन्यू रहना तभी मेरे अंदर
एनर्जी रहेगी नहीं आओगे फिर यार मजा नहीं
आता है ना जैसे अभी हो तो एनर्जी होती है
यार जब देखते हैं या काफी लोग हैं वो कर
रहे हैं 120 22 लोग हैं लाइक सिर्फ 90 है
तो लाइक तो मार दो यार लाइक तो ठोको लाइक
ठोकने में भाई कुछ नहीं जाता इतना तो
डिमांड कर ही सकता हूं भाई आपसे इतना तो
डिमांड चलता है है ना
चलो प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज के लिए नेसेसरी
है क्या सीखना है तो पाइथन सीख सकते हो बट
स्टार्टिंग के लिए अभी कोई जरूरत नहीं है
बट यू कैन गो विद द पाइथन ठीक है
स्टार्टिंग के लिए पाइथन के लिए जा सकते
हो बैश वगैरह के लिए कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं
चलो बिल्कुल बिल्कुल सारा कुछ बताऊंगा
सारा कुछ बताऊंगा टेंशन नहीं लेने का
टेंशन नहीं लेने का भाई टेंशन नहीं लेने
का तोय ये समझ में आ गया पब्लिक वर्सेस
प्राइवेट आपको ये भी समझ में आ गई होगी कि
पब्लिक प्रोग्राम जो यूजुअली लिस्टेड है
प्राइवेट के इन्विटेशंस आते हैं अगर आने
लगे तो आपके बल्ले-बल्ले हो जाएंगे भैया
ज्यादा चांसेस है आपके उसमें वलने
एबिलिटीज फाइंड करने के बक्स मिलने के
वैलिड बक्स मिलने के ज्यादा चांसेस है
वहां पे आपको मिल जाएंगे तो उसके लिए काम
कीजिए जहां पे आपको मिल जाए प्राइवेट
इन्विटेशन चलिए अब बात करते हैं ट्रायक
टीम या कंपनी ये बहुत बड़ा एक फैक्टर है
बहुत बड़ा एक फैक्टर है जो आपको डिसाइड
करना चाहिए जिसको यूज करना चाहिए हंट करने
के लिए प्रोग्राम पे काफी लोग इसको
नेगलेक्ट कर देते हैं ट्रायक टीम या फिर
कंपनी अब देखो मान लो अब यह क्या होता है
मैं आपको समझाता हूं बिल्कुल टेंशन नहीं
लेने का यह क्या होता है मैं आपको समझाता
हूं जैसे मान लो एक कंपनी है कौन सी कंपनी
है
भैया कोई भी उठा लो वन पासवर्ड मान लो ये
कंपनी है मैं एग्जांपल दे ये ऐसा करते
नहीं है बट मैं बस एग्जांपल दे रहा हूं अब
इस कंपनी में तुमने इसको अपना टारगेट चूज
किया क्या होता है प्रॉपर बग हंटिंग का
तरीका क्या होता है कि आप मल्टीपल टारगेट
के साथ मत जाओ ज्यादा ज्यादा ना हॉच पोस
नहीं करना किसी एक बढ़िया टारगेट को पहले
चूज करो जो मैं अभी तरीका बता रहा हूं उस
तरीके को यूज करके एक टारगेट को पहले सेट
करो कि यह टारगेट है मेरा और उसी टारगेट
पर एक महीने तक हंट
करो एंड मुझे तुम बताना कि तुम्हें वैलिड
बग नहीं मिला क्या एक एक महीने तक
ऑनेस्टली हंट करो और मुझे फिर बताना मुझे
मैसेज करके
करने लगोगे ना उसके स्कोप्स को ऐसे आंखें
बंद करना है तुम्हें उसके स्कोप्स को
उसके पैरेंट कंपनी जो अगर कोई है तो उसका
उसका चाइल्ड कंपनी है उसका उससे रिलेटेड
उसके जो डोमेन है उससे रिलेटेड सब डोमेंस
और उससे रिलेटेड अदर डोमेंस उस कंपनी में
कितने एंप्लॉयज काम करते हैं उस कंपनी के
एंप्लॉयज के कहां-कहां प्रोफाइल है उस
कंपनी के कितने नेटवर्क ब्लॉक्स है कितनी
आईपी रेंज है उस कंपनी के कितने डोमस सब
डोमस हैं सब डोमस के सब डोमस है थर्ड
फोर्थ फिफ्थ लेवल के सब डोमेन से सब डोमस
के अंदर के सब डोमेंस हैं उस कंपनी के
कितने गेट हब रिपोजिटरी है गेट हब
रिपोजिटरी में कौन सा प्रोग्रामर काम कर
रहा है कोडर काम कर रहा है उस कोडर के से
कांटेक्ट करके हम क्या कुछ डिटेल निकाल
सकते हैं कुछ सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का यूज कर
सकते हैं उस कंपनी के एंप्लॉई से क्या
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग का यूज करके कुछ ऐसा
डिटेल निकाल सकते हैं जिसको हम यूज करके
हंट कर सकते हैं मैं आंखें बंद करके सोच
रहा हूं तभी मैं आपको बता पा रहा हूं आप
जब सोचने लगोगे जब आप दिमाग में ऐसे घुमाओ
ग ना तो तुम्हें लग रहा होगा मेरा दिमाग
घूम गया है लेकिन मेरा दिमाग नहीं है आप
आप दिमाग घुमाओ यहां दिमाग में जब ऐसे
सोचोगे ना भैया तो तुम्हें समझ में आएगा
कि वाओ व्ट कूल इट इज देखो आंखें बंद कर
लिया है अब सोच रहे हो और ऑटोमेटिक
विजुलाइज होगा उस कंपनी के बारे में हर एक
चीज जान लेना है
तुम्हें और हर एक चीज जब जान जाओगे ना तो
ऐसे ऐसे तुम्हें वनबिल मिलेगी एंड तुम्हें
बग मिलेगा सच बता रहा हूं सच बता रहा हूं
वैलिड बग मिलेगा बाउंट वाली मिलेगी यही तो
नहीं कर पाते काफी लोग
टेक्निकली सोचते हैं अरे भाई टेक्निकली तो
ठीक है फंडामेंटली भी सोचो
ना ठीक है समझ में आ रहा है ना वो काम
करना है बस इतना ही बोलूंगा अब यह कंपनी
है मान लो अब इस पर तुम अपना पूरा टाइम
दिया एक महीना तुमने इस पर हंट किया तुमने
बहुत सारे बक्स भी रिपोर्ट कर दिए पता चले
पता चले कि यह कंपनी का रिस्पांस ही नहीं
है कुछ ज्यादा दे आर नॉट रेस्पॉन्डिंग
वेरी लाइक वेरी फास्ट या कुछ ऐसा कुछ
फास्ट रिस्पांस उनका है नहीं ऐसा तुम्हें
पता चल रहा है तो यह हर्ट होगा क्या होगा
यह हर्ट करेगा और हर्ट नहीं होना हर्ट
हर्ट नहीं होना अपन को इसलिए हम नहीं काम
कर रहे हैं वी आर नॉट सर्वेंट्स हम नौकर
नहीं है हम बग्स फाइंड कर रहे हैं ना वी
आर नॉट सर्वेंट्स ऑफ दोस कंपनीज वी आर
सिक्योरिटी रिसर्चस एंड उनको हमारी जरूरत
है हमें उनकी जरूरत नहीं है भाई ना ना ना
ना गलती नहीं भाई हमें
उनकी जरूरत नहीं है दे नीड अस दे नीड
अस वी डोंट नीड
देम तो हमें ना वह वाली माइंड सेट निकाल
देनी है और हमें अपने टाइम की वैल्यू को
समझनी है ट्स वई आई हैव रिटन दिस पॉइंट
ट्रायक टीम या कंपनी यानी कि रिस्पांस
टाइम उनका कैसा है कंपनी का एंड कंपनी का
ट्रायक टीम वो होता है जो आपके रिपोर्ट को
पढ़ रहा होता
है ठीक है प्लीज डोंट स्पैम विनय मिस्टर
विनय जी रिपोर्ट आप स्पैम मत कीजिए बारबार
एक ही मैसेज मत कीजिए प्लीज फिर मुझे आपको
वो करना पड़ जाएगा
प्लीज तो व आपका रिस्पांस टाइम कंपनी का
कैसा है वह देखना है वह समझना है वह अच्छा
है तभी आप उस कंपनी पर उस प्रोग्राम पर
टको अदर वाइज उसको छोड़ दो लीव ट
प्रोग्राम मूव न टू सम अदर प्रोग्राम एंड
वो जो ट्रक टीम होती है व आपको रिपोर्ट को
जो पढ़ रही होती है उनका रिस्पांस कैसा है
वो उस पे डिपेंड करता है अब ट्रायक टीम ने
क्या किया आपका रिपोर्ट ले लिया पढ़ लिया
वैलिड भी है अच्छा ठीक है कल करेंगे इनको
रिप्लाई अच्छा ठीक है दो दिन बाद इनको
रिस्पॉन्ड करेंगे अच्छा ठीक है एक महीने
बाद ही रिस्प करेंगे अरे भैया ये क्या है
ये सब्जी बाजार थोड़ी ना यार तुम यार मतलब
आज की सब्जी कल बेच दोगे कल की सब्जी दो
महीने बाद भी बेचो ग ये थोड़ी ना बात हुई
हमने अपना एफर्ट लगाया हमने अपना टाइम
दिया है हमने अपना कीमती समय दिया है आपके
कंपनी के सिक्योरिटी के लिए और आप हमारी
वैल्यू नहीं कर रहे हो करनी है वैल्यू
करनी चाहिए नहीं करोगे तो कैसे काम चलेगा
फिर तो कोई भी रिसर्चर आपके कंपनी पर हंड
नहीं करेगा आप ऐसे ही पढ़े रहोगे कोई
अटैकर हैकर आएगा आपकी कंपनी को उड़ा के
लेके चला जाएगा ब पता चलेगा बस गया भाई
समझ में आ रहा है ये चीज होती है गॉट
इट यस तो यह दिमाग में रखना है यही इसका
रिस्पांस टाइम जैसे जब आप इस पे आओगे नीचे
आओगे यहां पे तो यहां दिख रहा होगा
वैलिडेशन विद इन थ्री डेज तीन दिन के अंदर
ये वैलिडेट कर देते हैं एंड एक्सेप्ट
रिजेक्ट जो भी करना है कर देते हैं 25 पर
ऑफ सबमिशंस आर एक्सेप्टेड और रिजेक्टेड
विदन थ्री डेज इट्स अ वेरी गुड टाइम इट्स
अ वेरी गुड रिस्पांस टाइम ये अच्छा
रिस्पांस टाइम होता है ये अच्छा रिस्पांस
टाइम होता है तो ऐसी प्रोग्राम को आप जॉइन
कर सकते हैं अब ऐसा कोई प्रोग्राम भैया जो
अब पता नहीं रिस्पॉन्ड ही नहीं कर रहा है
कुछ भी नहीं कर रहा गोली मारो फिर देखना
है वलने बिटीज कितने रिवॉर्ड हुए 155 ठीक
है एवरेज पेआउट इनका 487 मतलब अच्छा खासा
बाउंट भी पे करते हैं
दैट्ची
वेरी वेरी गुड बस यही तो है यही तो है
आपका ट्रायक टीम या कंपनी को कंपनी को
देखना है भैया अपना टाइम वेस्ट नहीं करने
का कभी नहीं करना यह गलती मत करना कि हंट
कर रहे हैं रिप्लाई नहीं भी दे रहे फिर भी
उसी पर लगे ना छोड़ दो उसको गोली मारो देर
आर थाउजेंड ऑफ लक्स ऑफ टारगेट्स फॉर यू
वेटिंग फॉर
यू ठीक है और अब एक लास्ट यहां पे लास्ट
नहीं है अकॉर्डिंग टू द स्किल्स अब मान लो
मान लो तुम इस प्रोग्राम पे हंट कर रहे हो
वन पासवर्ड पे तुम नीचे आओगे नीचे आओगे
यहां पे हंटिंग के लिए दिए हुए हैं मान लो
एपीआई टेस्टिंग दी हुई है ठीक है मान लो
एए टेस्टिंग अब यह स्किल तुम्हें नहीं आती
तो तुम इसमें टाइम वेस्ट मत करो लीव दैट
प्रोग्राम अगर तुम्हें उस प्रोग्राम में
जो जो टेस्टिंग के लिए बोल रहे हैं अगर
तुम्हें वह चीज़ नहीं आती है ना उस पे
टाइम को वेस्ट नहीं करना है भैया यू डोंट
हैव
टू जस्ट लीव
इट जो स्किल्स आती है जो स्किल्स है अंदर
में उसको यूटिलाइज करना है आपको उस
पर्टिकुलर प्रोग्राम प तभी आपको सक्सेस
मिलेगा सक्सेस के चांसेस ज्यादा है डूप्स
कम मिलेंगे डूप्स मतलब डुप्लीकेट्स कम
मिलेंगे एंड चांसेस है कि वैलिड बग आपको
मिलेंगे क्योंकि जब है ही नहीं स्किल्स तो
क्यों हंट करना भाई क्यों जबरदस्ती लगना
नहीं लगना लीव इट
सिंपल ठीक है गट
इट
ओके अब यहां पर आते हैं वेब मोबाइल पप
अदर्स पे क्या है ये वेब एप्लीकेशन मोबाइल
एप्लीकेशन अदर्स पे जैसे कि मैंने एक
प्रोग्राम को आपको दिखाया था एंड दैट
प्रोग्राम अ वाज हब स्पॉट तो हब स्पॉट पे
चलते हैं लेट्स गो टू द हब स्पॉट इसमें
देखिए पा दिन के अंदर वैलिडेट करते हैं
गुड टाइमिंग ठीक है बहुत बुरा भी नहीं है
अच्छा है एवरेज बाउंट भी अच्छा है इनका
ठीक है एंड यहां पे इनका पेआउट भी ठीक है
$50 से शुरू करते हैं p4 के लिए आप वेट
लुक आउट कर सकते हैं p4 में आपके चांसेस
हैं मिलने
के उसके बाद अब आप आएंगे तो यहां पे ना
क्या होता है सबसे ज्यादा पॉपुलर कौन सा
प्लेटफॉर्म है जिसपे बाउंट लोग खोजते हैं
मुझे आप बताइए सबसे ज्यादा पॉपुलर
प्लेटफॉर्म कौन सा है प्लेटफॉर्म मतलब ये
ब्राड हैकर वाला नहीं मतलब वेबसाइट मोबाइल
एप्लीकेशन गिट हब रिपोजिटरी सोर्स कोड या
सबसे ज्यादा पॉपुलर क्या है जिस पे हैकर्स
सबसे ज्यादा हंट करते हैं मुझे बताइए आप
लोग लेट मी
नो प्लीज लेट मी
नो बता दीजिए
मुझे वेब ठीक है आदर्श इ सेइंग वेब सैयद
अली इ सेइंग
वेब ओके प्रने इज
एंड्राइड अक्षय वेबसाइट एनोनिमस दुनिया
वेबसाइट और बाइट
वेब स्पर्स वेब एप्लीकेशन ठीक
है शुभम सतर फाइनली आई गट फ्री रिसोर्स
थैंक यू सो मच डिफ अकेडमी वेलकम ब्रदर वेब
वेब ठीक
है वेब है बिल्कुल सही है जवाब बिल्कुल
सही है वेब एप्लीकेशन जो वेब एप्लीकेशन है
वेबसाइट जैसे हमारी वेबसाइट है ठीक है
हमारी वेबसाइट de.com मान लो ये वेबसाइट
है f.com ठीक है तो ये सबसे ज्यादा जो है
ना वेब एप्लीकेशंस पे लोग हंट करते हैं
रिसर्चस उससे कम पे आप आओगे तो फिर ज्यादा
मतलब बहुत ज्यादा रिसर्चस आपको नहीं
मिलेंगे अगर आप मोबाइल एप्लीकेशंस की बात
करो जैसे आप एंड एप्लीकेशन की बात करो
वहां पे रिसर्चस कम हो जाएंगे आईओ
एप्लीकेशन की बात करो और भी कम हो जाएंगे
एपीआई टेस्टिंग की बात करो उसमें भी आपको
कम मिलेंगे तो ऐसे जो है ना आप ऐसे स्कोप
को खोजो जिस पर रिसर्चस कम
है ट्राई टू हंट ऑन दैट जैसे कि यहां इनका
एक एंड एप्लीकेशन है एंड मोबाइल एप्लीकेशन
है आप इस परे
google's सीआरएम इनका एप्लीकेशन आप इस पे
हंट करने की कोशिश कर सकते हो फॉर गेटिंग
फॉर अ बेटर चांस टू गेट अ वैलिड ब फास्ट
या इनका आईओएस एप्लीकेशन है प स्टोर पे
आपको मिल जाएगा आप इस पर हंट करना ट्राई
कर सकते हो बट इसके लिए आपको यह स्किल्स
चाहिए आओ पेन टेस्टिंग एंड पेन टेस्टिंग य
चाहिए यह आपको सीखनी
पड़ेगी यह आपको सीखनी
पड़ेगी तो आप में से कितने लोग चाहते हैं
कि मैं आईओएस पेन टेस्टिंग तो मैं नहीं
करा सकता बिकॉज आईओएस मैंने अभी-अभी यूज
करना शुरू किया है बट बचपन से एड यूज कर
रहा हूं बचपन मतलब कि जब से आया है तब से
तो आप लोग में से कितने लोग चाहते हैं ए
पेन टेस्टिंग भी मैं आपको सिखाऊं या मेरे
टीम का कोई सिखाए जो भी सिखाएगा आपको
बेस्ट कंटेंट ही देगा ठीक है हाउ मेनी ऑफ
यू वांट कोई चाहता है ए पन टेस्टिंग भी
साथ में चल जाए मैं सिखा दूं या कोई भी
सिखा दे मेरी टीम
का 127 लोगों में से अगर 100 लोगों के
मैसेज आ गए कि ए प्र टेस्टिंग भी चाहिए
आपको सीखना है तो मैं स्टार्ट करवा सकता
हूं अभी नहीं करवाऊंगी कुछ दिनों के बाद
जब उसकी जरूरत पड़ेगी तब मैं करवा दूंगा
या कभी भी हो सकती है कोई ठीक नहीं
है ओके काफी लोगों को चाहिए कोई ना नहीं
बोलेगा सब पता है मुझे
सब पता है सब पता है कोई ना नहीं बोलेगा
कोई बात नहीं वेब एप्लीकेशन तो अभी चलेगी
आपकी अब देखो जो आप अभी सीख रहे हो ना
बेसिक धन्यवाद धन्यवाद धन्यवाद आप सबका
बहुत-बहुत धन्यवाद
धन्यवाद और स्ट्रीम को आप लोग शेयर करते
हो ना अपने कम्युनिटी में अपने ग्रुप्स
में शेयर कर देना ्र पर भी शेयर करना ए ा
प जब शेयर करना तो टैग कर देना टीम
फोनिक्स टेक्निकल नेविगेटर दोनों को आई
विल रि शेयर ठीक है तो अभी जो आप स्किल
सीख रहे हो ना बग बाउंट की आप ये स्किल्स
को एंड्राइड पेन टेस्टिंग प भी अप्लाई कर
सकते हो थोड़ा मेथड डिफरेंट है स्टेप्स
अलग हैं थोड़े से चेंज हो जाएंगे बट
कांसेप्ट वही रहेगा याद रखिएगा उसमें ओस
मोबाइल एप्लीकेशन जो है ना ओस का मोबाइल
टॉप 10 वो वाला आप यूज कर सकते हैं उसके
अलावा और भी बहुत सारी चीजें हैं वो मैं
आऊंगा जब तब आपको वो सारी चीजें पता
चलेंगी तो अब आपको अपने टारगेट के वो
स्कोप को चूज करना है जिस परे रिसर्चस कम
है जैसे मोबाइल एप्लीकेशन एड मोबाइल
एप्लीकेशन आओ मोबाइल एप्लीकेशन गिट हब
रिपोजिटरी हो गया या फिर आपका एपीआई
टेस्टिंग हो गई इन सब पे ज्यादा फोकस करना
है जब आप थोड़ा इंटरमीडिएट लेवल प चले
जाएंगे अभी नहीं बिगनर लेवल प नहीं करना
भाई बिगनर लेवल प तो वेब पेन टेस्टिंग ही
करनी है बिगनर लेवल पे यू हैव टू ओनली डू
वेब पेन
टेस्टिंग उसके अलावा अभी मत सोचना ज्यादा
मैं सब बताऊंगा सब कुछ लेकिन अभी वेब
पटेस्ट ठीक है तो वेब एप्लीकेशन मोबाइल
एप्लीकेशन या अदर्स में से आपको चूज करना
है एंड गिट अप रिपोजिटरीज भी होती है उसपे
भी आप टेस्टिंग कर सकते हो बहुत सारी
चीजें होती है तो आपको इस तरीके से अपना
माइंड सेट रखना है चलिए अब यहां पे बात
करते हैं एक टूल के बारे में जिसका नाम है
एसेट फाइंडर दिस इज अ टूल ये टूल है मैं
दिखा देता हूं आपको कहां है कहां ये पहले
मैं क्लोज कर देता
हूं ये एक टूल है एसेट फाइंडर बाय टॉम नॉम
नॉम ही इज अ सिक्योरिटी रिसर्चर एंड काफी
सीनियर पर्सन है बग बाउटी कम्युनिटी में
तो इनका एक टूल है एसेट फाइंडर आप इसका
यूज कर सकते हो क्या करता है ये टूल फाइंड
डोमस एंड सब डोमेंस पोटेंशियली रिलेटेड टू
अ गिवन डोमेन मतलब एक डोमेन से रिलेटेड जो
डोमस है सब डोमेंस है उसको फाइंड करता है
अब
खुद से देखेंगे रिकन का फेज का रिकन फेज
का ये बहुत ही अच्छा एक स्टेप है
इंपोर्टेंट स्टेप है तो हम बहुत सारी
चीजें करेंगे अभी तो बहुत बचा ही है यार
अभी तो अभी तो बस शुरुआत ही है ठीक है तो
आपको यह टूल आप यूज कर सकते हैं अब बात
करते हैं जैसे कि अब बात करते हैं
रिपोर्ट्स की रिपोर्ट्स की कितनी
इंपॉर्टेंट होती है कितना ज्यादा
इंपॉर्टेंट होता है वो हम उस पर बात करते
हैं ठीक है चलिए चलिए बिल्कुल बिल्कुल
देखते हैं हां एक यहां पे एक यूआरएल है
मैं आपको यूआरएल प्रोवाइड करता हूं ये
जाके पढ़िए आप लोग ये मैं आपको चैट में दे
देता हूं ठीक है यह आप सब लोग पढ़ना
एवरीवन रीड रीड दिस मैं यह चैट में भेज
रहा हूं यह मैंने आपको भेजा है आप इसको
पढ़िए सभी लोग पढ़िए ठीक है मीडियम का एक
आर्टिकल है जो मैंने लिखा हुआ है एंड यह
आर्टिकल में मैंने बताया है कैसे मैंने
यूनिवर्सिटी अपनी जो यूनिवर्सिटी थी उसकी
वेबसाइट को हैक किया था जब जब मैं कॉलेज
में था एंड उसने मेरी कैसे लाइफ चेंज की
थी लाइफ चेंज का मतलब होता है कि कैसे
मेरे लाइफ में टर्न ंग पॉइंट आया हुआ था
लाइफ चेंज का मतलब यह नहीं होता है कि मैं
गरीब से मिलियनेयर बन गया मैं मोटिवेशनल
स्पीकर नहीं हूं भाई यहां पे कि मैं आपको
यह सिखाऊंगा कि कि आप एक गरीब से
मिलियनेयर कैसे बने मिडिल क्लास से
बिलियने कैसे बने ये सब नहीं आपको लाइफ
चेंज का मतलब है कैसे टर्निंग पॉइंट आया
लाइफ में ये आर्टिकल आप पूरा पढ़िए बहुत
डिटेल में लिखा हुआ है एंड ये आर्टिकल
इसलिए बोल रहा हूं पढ़ने के लिए आपको एक
मोटिवेशन मिलेगा बहुत तगड़ा वाला मोटिवेशन
मिलेगा इस आर्टिकल को पढ़ के इस बात की
पूरी आपको मैं गारंटी देता हूं तगड़ी
आर्टिक आपको तगड़ी वाली आपको मोटिवेशन
मिलने वाली है तो प्लीज रीड इट ओके एवरीवन
रीड इट चलिए अब यहां पे बात करते हैं
कि
डायरेक्ट एक्टिविटी हैर one.com प जब आप
आएंगे इस पे अकाउंट क्रिएट कर लेंगे लॉगइन
कर लेंगे तो हैकर वन पे ना आपको एक
हैक्टिविटी का सेक्शन मिलेगा जब आप
एक्टिविटी सेक्शन प आएंगे तो आपको यहां पे
वह सारे रिपोर्ट्स मिलेंगे जो अभी
रिसेंटली या अभी किसी हैकर ने किसी
प्रोग्राम पर हंट करा है एंड उसको
डिस्क्लोज करा गया है उस रिपोर्ट को आपको
पढ़ना है दो दिन पहले का रिपोर्ट है यह दो
दिन पहले का दो दिन पहले का तीन दिन पहले
का तीन दिन पहले का कि कौन से बग
बाउंटीफुल
प्रोग्राम पर हंट किया कंपनी के कौन से
पर्टिकुलर डोमेन पर हंट किया या मोबाइल
एप्लीकेशन पर हंट किया या किसी पर्टिकुलर
एप्लीकेशन पर हंट किया एंड क्या वनबिल
फाइंड की उस वनबिल का नाम क्या था उसकी
सीवियरिंग क्या थी उनको कोई बाउंट या
रिवॉर्ड मिला कि नहीं मिला एंड वो रिजॉल्व
हुआ कि नहीं हुआ जैसे आपको यहां पर लिस्ट
दिख रही होगी जैसे ये क्रिटिकल है आरसी
मिला है
भैया ठीक है यूएस डिपार्टमेंट ऑफ डिफेंस
में आरसी मिला है इनको यहां पे क्रिटिकल
है बट रो डॉलर क्योंकि इनको इसका पैसा
नहीं दिया जाता है तो इन्होंने इसको
रिपोर्ट किया है तो इसका आपको रिपोर्ट
पढ़ना है रिपोर्ट पढ़ने से आपको बहुत
जानकारी मिलती है बहुत ज्यादा जानकारी
मिलती है देखो जैसे ये एक रिपोर्ट है अ ये
कोई रिसर्चर है उन्होंने नेक्स्ट क्लाउड
को रिपोर्ट किया है इस पर चलो क्लिक करते
हैं क्लिक करते हैं ये एक लो सीवियरिंग का
लेबिलिटी है जिसम इनको $100 का बाउंट मिला
है तो ये रिपोर्ट्स को आपको पढ़ना है जब
आप रिपोर्ट्स पढ़ेंगे ना तो आपको समझ में
आएगा कि कैसे एक हैकर एक सिक्योरिटी
रिसर्चर किसी पर्टिकुलर प्रोग्राम के लिए
अप्रोच करता है किसी पर्टिकुलर बग के लिए
अप्रोच करता है उसको फाइंड करता है क्या
स्टेप्स होते हैं उसमें आपको बहुत आईडिया
मिलेगा स्टेप्स का जो स्टेप्स यू हैव टू
यू शुड टेक टू फाइंड पर्टिकुलर वल एबिलिटी
इन्होंने क्या किया एडमिंस कैन चेंज
ऑथेंटिकेशन डिटेल्स ऑफ यूजर
कॉन्फिडो मेज यूजर का कोई कंफिट स्टोरेज
है उसके ऑथेंटिकेशन डिटेल्स को चेंज कर
सकता
है ठीक है समझ में आ रहा है तो यहां पे
इसके इन्होंने मतलब एक सिक्योरिटी एडवा
एडवाइजरी भी जारी कर दी है इससे रिलेटेड
एंड यहां यहां पर इस रिसर्च ने इसको पूरा
एक्सप्लेन कर रहा है पूरा कि आफ्टर सम
टेस्टिंग इन नेक्स्ट क्लाउड सर्वर आई
फाउंड इंप्रोपर एक्सेस कंट्रोल इंप्रोपर
एक्सेस कंट्रोल मेक यूजर्स इन एडमिन ग्रुप
टू चेंज एनी ग्लोबल क्रेडेंशियल फॉर एडमिन
या यूजर एक्सटर्नल स्टोरेज यह बहुत मतलब
नहीं होना चाहिए ऐसा शुड नॉट हैपन लाइक
दिस कि एक एडमिन ग्रुप का कोई यूजर है वो
गल क्रेडेंशियल को चेंज कर दे रहा है
एडमिन के लिए तो यह एक व बिलिटी हो
गई ठीक है अब इनको इन्होंने क्या किया
स्टेप्स बताया कैसे रीप्रोड्यूस करना है
इन्होंने अपना पूरा कोड यहां पर मेंशन
किया सारा कुछ दिया यहां पर एंड इन्होने
स्टेप्स बताए कि कैसे कैसे करके इसको
रीप्रोड्यूस किया जा सकता है जब यह
रिपोर्ट तुम पढ़ोगे तो तुम्हें समझ
तुम्हारा माइंड ओपन होगा तु माइंड ब्रॉड
होगा तुम्ह समझ में आएगा अरे यार ये क्या
हो रहा है अरे यार ये कैसे हो अरे यार ऐसी
चीज हो रही है इतना भी कुछ होता है ऐसी
चीज ऐसे स्टेप्स ले
और इसके लिए मैं तुम्हें एक बुक बताता हूं
उस बुक को ना तुम मैं दिखाता हूं तुम्ह वो
बुक तुम सब पढ़ो अब इप प्रॉपर एक्सेस
कंट्रोल इसके बारे में तुम्हें नहीं पता
होगी तुम्हें जानना चाहिए अब उसके लिए एक
बुक मैं दिखाता हूं तुम लोगों को यह बुक
है पता नहीं दिख रहा है कि
नहीं यह बुक है दिस बुक इज वेब एप्लीकेशन
हैकर्स हैंड बुक ये आपको दिख रही होगी वेब
एप्लीकेशन हैकर्स हैंडबुक यह बुक जो है आप
सबको प पढ़नी है चाहे आप इसका पीडीएफ
वर्जन ले लो कहीं पे इंटरनेट प आपको मिल
जाएगी आराम से अगर आप पीडीएफ में
कंफर्टेबल है पीडीएफ पढ़ने में तो यू कैन
गो फॉर द पीडीएफ वर्जन अगर आप पीडीएफ में
नहीं है तो आप इस बुक को परचेज कर सकते
हैं थोड़ी कॉस्टली पड़ेगी बट ठीक है आप यू
कैन परचेज इसका नाम है वेब एप्लीकेशन
हैकर्स
हैंडबुक ठीक है आपको कहीं पे भी मिल जाएगा
ऑनलाइन वेब एप्लीकेशन हैकर्स दिस इज अ
वेरी इंपोर्टेंट वेब एप्लीकेशन को पढ़ने
के लिए समझने के लिए दिस इज वेरी
इंपोर्टेंट ठीक है तो आपको ये रिपोर्ट्स
पढ़ने है एक्टिविटी पे आके आप बग क्राउड
पे भी आओगे तो यहां पे आपको एक क्राउड
स्ट्रीम मिलेगा तो क्राउड स्ट्रीम में
हालांकि बहुत ज्यादा यहां पे रिपोर्ट्स
पब्लिश नहीं होते हैं बट स्टिल आप
जहां-जहां भी हो रहे हैं जो जो हो रहे हैं
आप इनको पढ़ सकते हैं आप उनको देख सकते
हैं कि अगर कुछ इनमें रिपोर्ट या कुछ
डिटेल है तो आप इनको समझ सकते हैं आप उसको
देख के पता कर सकते हैं आपको बहुत नॉलेज
मिलेगी एक्चुअली में कि एक्चुअल रिपोर्ट्स
पढ़ पढ़ के आपको आपकी जानकारी ऑटोमेटिक
बढ़ेगी तो ये आपको काम करना है रिपोर्ट्स
पढ़ने हैं अब यहां पे टारगेट चूज करने का
तो आपको समझ में आ गया कैसे चूज करना है
अब टारगेट चूज करने का एक और तरीका
अब यूजुअली क्या होता है गा देखो यूजुअली
आप टारगेट चूज करोगे तो यूजुअली आप टारगेट
कहां पर चूज करोगे अच्छा आपको अगर मैंने
बोला कि जाओ एक टारगेट चूज करो अभी अभी एक
जाओ एक टारगेट चूज करो जिस पर आपको हंट
करना है वलने बिलिटी बक्स फाइंड करने है
आप कहां से चूज करोगे मुझे बताओ आप में से
सारे लोग बताओ सारे लोग बताओ प्लीज लेट मी
नो कहां से आप टारगेट चूज करोगे च
प्लेटफॉर्म
बताइए मुझे कहां से आप चूज करोगे जल्दी
बताइए बताइए जल्दी जल्दी जल्दी डोंट बी
लेट जल्दी
बताइए देख रहा हूं
मैं जल्दी
जल्दी
ओके बक क्राउड हैकर वन बक क्राउड हैकर वन
ग डॉक ठीक है बक क्राउड
बढ़िया अमेजन से कौन करता है
भाई ठीक
है थारा भाई जोगिंदर येय क्या है भाई सीवी
क्या है सीवी क्या है वही है कॉमन वटी ए
एक्सपोजर होते हैं बताऊंगा उसपे भी
आऊंगा ठीक है काफी लोगों का है हैकर वन पे
जाएंगे बग क्राउड पे आएंगे या आप ओपन बग
बाउंट पे भी आ जाओगे ना ओपन बग
बाउंट गट चूज कर सकते हो देखो ये तो आपके
तरीके हैं जो भी बग बाउंट प्लेटफॉर्म्स है
आप उस परे टारगेट्स जाके चूज कर सकते हो
जैसा मैंने आपको बताया अलग-अलग आपको ये
अलग-अलग जो है ना अ कंडीशंस आपको फॉलो
करने हैं ठीक है अलग-अलग चीजें आपको ध्यान
में रखनी है
जैसे स्कोप के बारे में पब्लिक प्राइवेट
के रिवॉर्ड के ट्रैक टीम के बारे में
स्किल्स को मोबाइल एप्लीकेशन वेब
एप्लीकेशन इन सब को ध्यान में रखते हुए
जैसे क्लासिफाई मैंने करने का आपको सिखाया
वैसे ही आपको करना है चूज अब चूज करने के
लिए आप ओपन बग बाउंट प्लेटफॉर्म चूज कर
सकते हो ओपन बग बाउंट इज अ वेरी गुड
प्लेटफॉर्म फॉर चूज इंग अ टारगेट फॉर अ
फॉर अ बिगनर पर्सन जो बिगनर है उसके लिए
बहुत ज्यादा अच्छा है क्योंकि यहां पे
आपको कंट्री स्पेसिफिक डोमेंस और टारगेट्स
मिल जाते हैं हालांकि आपको ये नहीं देखना
कि इनके अंदर क्या स्कोप के आइटम्स है
जैसे मान लो मैं यहां पे नीचे जाता हूं
ठीक ठीक है अब यहां देखो कोई एक टारगेट
देखो यहां पर अलग-अलग तरह के तुमहे टारगेट
दिखेंगे जैसे ये देखो कपथ गोटी य थाईलैंड
का कोई कंपनी होगा थाईलैंड की कोई डोमेन
होगी अब यह अजीप टाइप का टारगेट है अलग ही
टारगेट है ऐसे टारगेट को खोजो इसम वटी
मिलने के चांसेस तुम्हारे बढ़ जाएंगे
ज्यादा यू हैव ग्रेटर चांस टू गेट अ वैलिड
बग ऑन दिस टाइप ऑफ टारगेट्स तो ऐसे टारगेट
को चूज करो जैसे ये
सीए
मंदीप शरा स ये भी एक कंट्री स्पेसिफिक
टारगेट है ठीक है rb.com ये भी एक कंट्री
स्पेसिफिक टारगेट है तो ऐसे टारगेट्स को
यू हैव टू
सिलेक्ट जो कंट्री स्पेसिफिक थोड़ डिफरेंट
टारगेट्स हैं तो इसके लिए ओपन बग बाउंट इज
द बेस्ट प्लेटफॉर्म उसके बाद जेनरिक
टारगेट्स को अग आपको चूज करना है जाना है
तो यू शुड गो टू द बक
क्राउड यहां पे ब्राउट प चले जाओ
प्रोग्राम्स पे चले जाओ एंड यहां पे भैया
बहुत सारे प्रोग्राम्स में मिल जाएंगे
जस्ट गो एंड चूज द
प्रोग्राम्स जो चूज करने करो उसके बाद आप
चले जाओ हैकर वन पे यहां पर अपॉर्चुनिटी
में जाओ या डायरेक्टरी प जाओ और यहां पर
जो भी प्रोग्राम से इसको चूज करो यहां से
आप प्रोग्राम चूज कर सकते हो अब एक थोड़ा
डिफरेंट अप्रोच क्या है प्रोग्राम चूज
करने का वह मैं आपको बताता हूं एंड वह जो
मेथड है वह जो मेथड है मैं इसको पहले
क्लोज कर देता
हूं इसको भी क्लोज कर देता हूं फ्रक्स
इसको रहने देते हैं वो मेथड है डॉर्किंग
का अरे ओपन बग बाउंट में रिप्लाई आए ना आए
उससे मतलब नहीं है यार ओपन बग बाउंट में
आपको रिप्लाई आया नहीं आ उससे मतलब नहीं
है मैं क्या बोल रहा हूं यू डोंट हैव टू
हंट एट स्टार्ट फॉर गेटिंग अ रिप्लाई और
गेटिंग अ कन्फर्मेशन कुछ नहीं भैया अगर आप
हंट कर रहे हो प्रोग्राम प और अगर आपको
लगता है मेरे को बग मिला है वह वैलिड है
आपको अपने अंदर वो लाना है कि मेरे को पता
चल जाए कि वैलिड है कि नहीं है तो फिर आप
उस परे हंट करो वैलिड फाइंड करो आप अपने
आप को संतुष्टि दो अपने मन को संतुष्टि दो
कि मैंने वैलिड वर्क फाइंड किया ठीक है
आपको अभी आपको अभी रिप्लाई के लिए हॉल ऑफ
फेम के लिए नहीं सोच ना है वो ऑटोमेटिक
आपका हो जाएगा जब जैसे-जैसे आप आगे बढ़ो ग
यू विल ऑटोमेटिक गेट ऑन दैट कि आपको
रिप्लाई भी आ रहा है सब कुछ हो रहा है हां
ओपन बग बाउंट थोड़ा सा अजीब है कई सारे
प्रोग्राम्स में आपको रिप्लाई नहीं मिलता
है कुछ में मिल भी जाते हैं तो बट स्टिल
आपके ये स्कोप के लिए या फिर आपके ये
टारगेट के लिए बेस्ट ऑप्शन है टारगेट चूज
करके अपनी प्रैक्टिसेस कर सकते हो एक
वैलिड बग मिलने तक कर सकते हो उसके बाद ब
क्राउड और फिर हैकर वन प आप आ सकते हो अब
एक डिफरेंट अप्रोच क्या है
आपके टारगेट फाइंड करने का वह है ग
डॉर्क ग
डॉक्स तो आपको ग डॉक्स का यूज करके भी
टारगेट फाइंड करना
है ठीक है अब आप सोच रहे होंगे कि
है ना और भी लोग तो यूज करते हैं ना
वक बाउंट रिसोर्सेस फोल्डर में ये भी मैं
आपको वहां पर अपलोड कर दूंगा इसको अपडेट
कर दूंगा तो जो लोग जवाइन नहीं है जवाइन
कर लीजिएगा प्लीज ठीक है एड एप्लीकेशन
डेनिक्स एडमी डाउनलोड इंस्टॉल कीजिए लॉग
इन कीजिए जवाइन कीजिए ठीक है तो यहां पे
अब यहां पे मे पास बहुत सारे डॉग्स है अब
इन डॉग्स का यूज करके आपको टारगेट फाइंड
करना है जैसे मान लो एक डॉक है इन यूआरएल
रिस्पांसिबल डिस्क्लोजर एंड मुझे चाहिए
सिर्फ स्वग वाले मिले स्वैग वाले मुझे
बाउंट नहीं चाहिए अभी तो मैंने यह डॉक
उठाया
google3 लगा सकते हो अगर चाहिए लेटेस्ट
वाले चाहिए तो 2023 लगा दो और एंटर मार
दो ठीक है अब यहां पे तुम्हें जो लिस्ट
मिलेंगी ना इन लिस्ट में से मैक्सिमम जो
आपके प्रोग्राम्स होंगे वो आपको हैकर ऑन
बक राउट प जनरली नहीं मिलेंगे या आपको
एक्सटर्नल बग बाउंट प्रोग्राम्स है जो
हैकर ऑन ब्राउट प ऑन बोर्डेड नहीं य अपना
खुद का प्राइवेट चलाते हैं मतलब खुद का ही
अपना प्रोग्राम चला
रहे खुद का ही चला
रहे ठीक है तो आपको क्या करना है इस तरीके
से डॉग को ग में सर्च कर लेना है ठीक है ग
में आपको सर्च कर लेनी है एंड यहां पर अब
आपको प्रोग्राम्स मिल जा रहे
है अब यहां पर भी जब आप इन प्रोग्राम्स को
ओपन करोगे जैसे इनको इनको मैं ओपन कर रहा
हूं ठीक है तो यहां पर जाओगे क्योंकि हमने
स्वग वाला किया था
तो यहां पर
यहां देखो यहां पर इन्होंने क्या लिखा है
अपार्ट फ्रॉम आवर हार्ट फेल्ट थैंक्स फॉर
वैलिड सबमिशन वी डोंट प्रोवाइड एनी कैश
रिवार्ड्स स्वक्स और अदर अल्टरनेटिव
रिवार्ड्स ए एट दिस टाइम अब यह कंपनी सबसे
बढ़िया टारगेट है मेरे लिए तो तुम सोचोगे
कि अरे यार इसमें तो ना कैश है ना रिवर्ड
है ना यह बेचारे
मतलब स्वग भी नहीं दे रहे हैं कोई बाउंट
भी नहीं दे रहे कोई रिवर्ड भी नहीं दे रहे
कुछ दे ही नहीं रहे
तो भैया यही तो चाहिए स्टार्टिंग में अभी
तो स्टार्टिंग में यही तो चाहिए भाई नहीं
चाहिए मुझे यार बाउंट मुझे नहीं चाहिए
बाउंट आपको भी नहीं चाहिए बिलीव मी आपको
भी नहीं चाहिए
बाउटी ऐसा ही चाहिए जिसमें कि यह कुछ नहीं
दे रहे हो एक थैंक यू बोल रहे हो अब ऐसे
जगह प ना वैलिड बग मिलने के चांसेस बढ़
जाते हैं और जब वैलिड बग आपका स्टार्टिंग
में एक दो मिल जाएगा ना यार तीन चार पा 10
ऐसे तो तुम्हारा कॉन्फिडेंस एक अलग लेवल
पर जाएगा भैया एक ऐसे ऐसे चढ़ जाओगे सीधा
सीधा तुम सीढ़ी चढ़ जाओगे वही करना है
पहले वही मेरा एम है कि आप वही करो पहले
एक वैलिड बग निकालो एक थैंक यू ही मिले
भाई चलो चलेगा मस्त मजे से थैंक यू मिले
बस
दैट्ची मिल गया हो
गया तो ऐसे प्रोग्राम को आपको फाइंड करना
है उसके बाद इनके रूल्स पढ़ लेने हैं आउट
ऑफ स्कोप वलन बिलिटी पढ़ लेनी है ये सारी
चीजें पढ़ लेनी है एंड कैसे रिपोर्ट करना
है वो सारी चीजें पढ़ के एंड देन आपको
अपना काम शुरू कर देना
है अब यहां पे भी इनका ऐसे ही
है इनका ऐसा ही है यह यहां पे दे रहे हैं
सारा कुछ यहां पे नीचे आओगे डिटेल्स यहां
पे मिलेंगे सारे
कुछ एवरीथिंग यहां पे आओगे ये भी इनका
रिस्पांसिबल डिस्क्लोजर है यू कैन हंट ऑन
दिस रूल्स यहां पे दे रखे हैं रिक्वेस्ट
फॉर कंपनसेशन यहां पे यहां पे दे रखा है
वी डू नॉट प्रोवाइड मॉनेटरी कंपनसेशन फॉर
एनी वले एबिलिटी रिपोर्टेड रिक्वेस्टिंग
कंपनसेशन विल मेक
यू नॉन कंप्ला विद पॉलिसी ठीक है ना समझ
में आ रहा है य पर रॉकेट लेन मे हाउ एवर
चूज टू सेंड स्वग एट इट्स ओन डिस्कशन यह
स्वग भेज भी सकते हैं अपने डिस्क्रिप्शन
पर अब यहां तो आपने यह चीज फाइंड कर ली अब
यहां पर बात आती है कि यह तो चलो यह तो
तुमने लिस्ट कर ली प्रोग्राम्स को अब
इसमें भी थोड़ा फिल्टर लगाने है फिल्टर
लगाना है फिल्टर टूल्स प आना है य एनी
टाइम लिखा हुआ है मुझे चाहिए ना
लास्ट मुझे चाहिए लास्ट वन वीक में जो
प्रोग्राम से वही मुझे
चाहिए फिल्टर प आना है पास्ट वन वीक पास्ट
वीक पर क्लिक कर देना है और पास्ट वीक
वाले जो अपडेटेड प्रोग्राम्स होंगे जिसमें
कुछ अपडेट आया कुछ ऐसा हुआ व आपको य
रिफ्लेक्ट कर जाए तो आपको उन प्रोग्राम्स
पर देखना है फिर पास्ट वाले पर छोड़ के अब
मुझे क्या करना है पास्ट वीक से पास्ट 24
आर्स में चले आना है पास्ट 24 आवर्स में
कोई है तो यह देख लेना भैया है कुछ कुछ तो
य मिल र है बढ़िया ज्यादा नहीं है ब ठीक
है जो भी है पास्ट मंथ का फिर देख सकते हो
फिर आपको य पर और भी मिल रहे हैं अब जैसे
पास्ट वीक में मैंने कर दिया तो मेरे
रिजल्ट चेंज हो गए अब मुझे यहां पर
जैसे य नाइकी का है चलो यह तो बहुत पॉपुलर
है यहां
पर नीचे आ जाते
हैं नीचे आ जाते हैं नीचे आ जाते हैं नीचे
आ जाते हैं लेट्स कम डाउन लेट्स कम डाउन
लेट्स कम डाउन यहां पर कुछ और अगर मिलता
है तो मिल जाएगा तो अच्छी बात है नॉ नथिंग
नथिंग नथिंग नथिंग नथिंग अब रिस्पांस
डिस्क्लोजर स्वैग है ना इस स्वैग को हटा
देते हैं एक बार स्वैग को हटा के सीधा
लिखते हैं ऐसे फिर देखते हैं
nike's ये आ रहा है पास्ट वीक वाला पास्ट
वीक वाला है ना ये पास्ट वीक वाला ये हां
तो एक आ रहा है आपका ग्रे अ ग्रेल्स का
इसके बाद जल्डर वी भी आ रहा है ये सारी
चीजें आ रही है तो आप इनको टारगेट्स को ले
सकते हैं जैसे ग्रेल्स का वर्क बाउंट
प्रोग्राम है यहां पे आपको दिख रहा हो यह
रिवार्ड्स भी देते हैं ये डायरेक्ट चला
रहे हैं दे आर गिविंग रिवार्ड्स यहां
मिनिमम रिवार्ड्स जो है ना लो के लिए जीरो
है लेकिन अगर मैक्सिमम रिवार्ड्स की बात
करें तो 200 है यहां पे इनका जो सबसे
मैक्सिमम है वह $3000 का है एंड यहां पे
यह कैसे-कैसे इन्होंने बाउंटीज रिवॉर्ड
करी है यह सारी लिस्ट यहां पे दे रखे हैं
इन्होंने पूरा बहुत डिटेल में यहां पे
दिया हुआ है सारा कुछ दिया हुआ है ए टू जड
चीज दिया हुआ है एंड यहां पे आप
सिक्योरिटी @ gril.com से इनको नोटिफाई कर
सकते हैं तो ऐसे टारगेट्स आपके स्कोप में
होना
चाहिए उसी तरीके से यह है जल्डर
रिस्पांसिबल डिस्क्लोजर प्रोग्राम यहां पे
आपको देख रहे हैं कि आपको यह डिटेल यहां
पे दे रखी है यहां पे इनकी डिटेल्स देखिए
एंड इनको आप रिपोर्ट कर सकते हैं जो भी है
यहां पे ईमेल करना है क्या टू रिस्पांसिबल
डिस्क्लोजर रड आ उसी तरीके से ये है
स्क्वाड कास्ट जो मैंने आपको बताया ही तो
ऐसे भी आप जो अपने टारगेट्स है वो फाइंड
कर सकते हैं यू कैन फाइंड योर ओन टारगेट्स
क्लियर है
भाई प्रोग्राम वैलिड है भाई वैलिड है आप
हां वैलिड अब देखो ये कैसे पता चलेगा कि
ये लोग रेस्पों करते हैं कि नहीं करते हैं
ये फेक नहीं है फेक मतलब इनका डिस्क्लोजर
प्रोग्राम नहीं है इसका कोई आईडिया आपको
नहीं लग सकता है जब तक कि आप उस परे हंट
ना करें यही सबसे बड़ी प्रॉब्लम की बात है
या अगर कोई आपका कॉलीग है या कोई आपका
कम्युनिटी में कोई हंटर आपका नोन है अगर
उसने पहले हंट किया है उसको पता है इसके
बारे में उसकी एक्सपीरियंस है कि भैया ये
तो फालतू कंपनी है ये हमें हमें क्या
रिस्पांस नहीं करते हैं सही से या बग्स को
सॉल्व भी देखो कई सारी कंपनीज पता है कैसी
होती है आप रिपोर्ट करोगे व आपके बग जो आप
रिपोर्ट करोगे वैलिड भी होगी वो उसको
करेक्ट कर लेंगे उसको मिटिगेट कर देंगे
फिक्स कर देंगे एंड फिर भी बोलेंगे कि
नहीं हम तो ये मानते ही नहीं है कि ये बग
था हम तो ये मानेंगे नहीं कि इसमें एक भग
थी यह तो हमारा एक इ थोड़ा सा एक एक
टेंपररी एक इशू था वो हमने फिक्स कर लिया
ऐसी कंपनी से दूर रहने
का बिल्कुल क्लियर दूर रहने
का ठीक है तो आप जब तक हंट नहीं करोगे यू
विल नॉट गेट टू नो कि वह कंपनी या वो
प्रोग्राम कैसा है जब आप हंट करो अगर आपको
लगे कि ये प्रोग्राम सही नहीं है जस्ट लीव
दैट प्रोग्राम मूव टू सम अदर प्रोग्राम
आपका यही होना चाहिए आपका माइंडसेट यही
होना चाहिए आपको आपका माइंडसेट ये नहीं
होना चाहिए कि उसी में घुसे पड़े हैं ठीक
है योर माइंड श माइंडसेट शुड नॉट बी लाइक
दैट कि आप उसी में घुसे तो इस तरीके से
आपको फाइंड करना है ठीक
है थैंक यू अहमद थैंक यू अहमद राजा थैंक
यू सो मच अरे आप लोग बस आप लोग का सपोर्ट
रहा इसी तरीके से यह इतना वो रहा ना
इंगेजमेंट इतना ज्यादा इंगेजमेंट रहा तो
भाई अभी तो कंटेंट ऐसे ऐसे आएंगे कि तुम
सोच नहीं सकते तुम्हें डाउट होने लगेगा कि
फ्री में इतना कुछ मिलता भी है
क्या
ओके बॉब शूट भी करेंगे भाई बॉब शूट भी
स्टार्ट करेंगे बब शूट तो सिखाऊंगा ना
बिना बप शूट के कैसे पढ़ोगे आगे करेंगे
यार अ एक ही क्लास में सब कुछ कैसे कराए
यार सब करेंगे टेंशन मत लो अच्छा तुम लोग
में से बहुत हरड़ बड़ाने वाले कौन-कौन है
यार मुझे ये बताओ मुझे कौन बताओ मुझे कि
कौन हड़ बड़ाने वाले लोग है जो बहुत जल्दी
हरबड़ा जाते हैं अब मैं बताओ एक ही क्लास
में सब कैसे करा दूं एक स्टेप वाइज मैंने
जो बना रखा है जो मैंने सोच रखा है उसी वे
में ले चलने दो ज्यादा बेटर है आपको
ज्यादा अच्छा क्वालिटी कंटेंट मिलेगा ठीक
है तो हरबड़ा मत यार ठीक है हर बड़ाने
वाला काम मत करो या हर बड़ी में जो काम है
ना वोह गड़बड़ी वाली हो जाती है यह पता है
ना
आपको ठीक
है सो डोंट गेट ओवर
चलिए तो ये आपको समझ में आ गया इस तरीके
से
रिकॉन इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग का स्टेप और
रिकॉन की जो माया है वो आपकी स्टार्ट हो
जाएगी और रिकॉन की माया स्टार्ट कीजिए फिर
फाइंड करना शुरू कीजिए अब वो रिकॉन भी
स्टार्ट करने से पहले मैं
आपको कुछ चीजें जो है वो भी बताऊंगा
ओबवियसली बॉब शूट के बारे में बताऊंगा
आपको और भी चीजें हैं वो भी बताऊंगा कैसे
क्या करना है थोड़ा कुछ और सेटअप बताऊंगा
तभी तो हम उस पे पहुंचेंगे ना रिकॉन करना
शुरू भी करेंगे उसके पहले मैं आपको एक
टास्क दे देता हूं ये टास्क सबके लिए है
गाइ यू हैव यू ऑल हैव टू डू दिस टास्क यू
ऑल हैव टू डू दिस टास्क टास्क करोगे कि
नहीं करोगे नेक्स्ट क्लास के पहले नेक्स्ट
क्लास कल नहीं होगी मोस्ट प्रोबेबली परसों
ही होगी इसी टाइम पे लेकिन उसके पहले
टास्क दे रहा हूं मैं आपको ट्राई हैक मी
पे आना है ट्राई हैक मी पे लॉग इन कर लेना
है यानी अकाउंट फ्री अकाउंट जो भी है आपके
पास अकाउंट बना लेनी
है ठीक है लर्न वाले बटन पर क्लिक करना है
यहां सर्च पर क्लिक करना है लर्न प जाकर
सर्च प आ जाना है ओके यहां पर आना है यहां
पर आपको सर्च वाले ऑप्शन में यहां पर सर्च
में आके यहां पर ओ सर्च करना है
ओप यह सर्च कर लेनी है अब ओ सर्च करोगे तो
यहां पर आपको एक मिलेगा ओ टॉप 10
2021 ओस टॉप 10
2021 यह आपको मिलेगा इस पर क्लिक करना
है ठीक है ओस टॉप 10 यह आपको सर्च कर लेना
है इसमें आ जाना है और इसको इस ओस टॉप 10
वाले वॉक थ्रू को आपको पूरा पढ़ना है एंड
इसमें अगर कोई ऐसी छोटी-मोटी टास्क है तो
उसको सॉल्व कर लेना है इसको आपको कंप्लीट
करने का है बिल्कुल कितने टास्क है इसमें
टोटल 23 टास्क है 23 नहीं है 22 ही है 22
ही है आपको ये 22 टास्क बहुत छोटे-छोटे
हैं यार बहुत आसान है इनको क्या करना है
इनको एक्सपेंड करना है और पढ़ना है जिसमें
नो आंसर नीडेड है उसको भी पूरा पढ़ना है
भैया इसमें नो आंसर नीडेड है ना तो दिस
रूम ब्रेक्स ईच ओएस टॉपिक डाउन एंड
इंक्लूड्स डिटेल्स ऑन द लेबिलिटी आपको
इसको पढ़ना है कि कौन-कौन से टॉप 10 है
यहां पे पढ़ो और जिसमें नो आंसर नीडेड है
उसको कंप्लीटेड पैसे क्लिक कर दोगे ये
आपका कंप्लीट हो जाएगा उसके बाद एक्सेसिंग
मशीनस तो मशीनस को एक्सेस करने का ये बता
रहे हैं तो चलिए भैया एक्सेस मशीन करके
फ्री वाला ओपन वीपीएन वाला बता ही रखा है
मैंने कैसे करना है तो ये कर लेना है
स्टार्ट मशीन पे क्लिक कर देनी है और वो
आपका हो जाएगा जब स्टार्ट मशीन कर दिया है
तो कंप्लीटेड कर दो और आपका यह वाला जो
पार्ट है यह भी आपका डन दो कंप्लीट उसके
बाद ब्रोकन एक्सेस कंट्रोल पे आना है इसको
पढ़ना है पूरा पढ़ना ही है बस और कुछ नहीं
करना है कंप्लीटेड पे क्लिक कर देना है
चौथे पे आना है इसको पूरा पढ़ना है सिर्फ
एक का पढ़ना है यहां पे यहां पे आपको कोई
कुछ नहीं करना है यहां पे
डिप्लॉयड में एक फ्लैग ढूंढना है आपको
सबमिट कर देनी है
दैट्ची है
दैट्ची नहीं है ऐसी वीडियोस तो नहीं आएंगी
भाई ऐसी वीडियो ऐसे
देखो आप अगर टॉ टॉपिक वाइज वीडियोस बोलोगे
तो आप लाइन वाइज नहीं सीख पाओगे आप एक एक
तरीके से नहीं सीख पाओगे बग बाउंट में ठीक
है और अगर आप ऑलरेडी जानते हो तो आप स्किप
कर सकते हो अभी के लिए जब आप इंटरमीडिएट
लेवल प आप सीखना हो तो आप आ सकते हो कोई
बात नहीं क्योंकि मैं यह जो बग बाउंट
ट्रेनिंग चला रहा हूं मैं सिर्फ उनके लिए
नहीं चला रहा जो ऑलरेडी जानते हैं मैं
उनके लिए चला रहा हूं जिनको कुछ नहीं पता
है जो एकदम बिगनर से सीखना चाहते हैं तो
मैं उनका ध्यान में रख के ही चलूंगा अपने
अकॉर्डिंग चलूंगा तो मुझे अपने अकॉर्डिंग
चलने दीजिए आपको बेस्ट कंटेंट मिलेगा अगर
आप मुझे डेविएशन करने की कोशिश करेंगे कि
नहीं ये ला दो वो ला दो फिर आपको कंटेंट
वो क्वालिटी नहीं मिलेगी यह बात मैं पूरी
गारंटी के साथ बोलता हूं कंटेंट तो मिल
जाएगा क्वालिटी विल नॉट बी देयर तो डिसाइड
क्वालिटी चाहिए कि कंटेंट चाहिए सीधी सी
बात है ठीक
है फ्लैग क्या होता है फ्लैग एक पीस ऑफ
इंफॉर्मेशन होती है जो किसी एक पर्टिकुलर
टास्क को जब आप परफॉर्म करोगे तो वहां पे
आपको इंटेंशनली रखी हुई होती है वो
इंफॉर्मेशन वो आपको ढूंढ के निकालनी पड़ती
है वही फ्लैग है जैसे मैंने ने बोला ये
ढूंढ के ये सामान लेकर आओ जो सामान लेकर
आओगे वो फ्लैग है वही है ठीक
है गॉट
इट चलिए ओके प्राइम जी ओके ओके तो ये
टास्क सब लोग कर लोगे मुझे बता दो ओ टॉप
10 2021 वाला ये टास्क सब लोग कर लोगे
प्लीज लेट मी नो गाइस ये टास्क कर लेना है
आपको ठीक है ओ सर्च करना है आपको ये टास्क
कर लेना है और एक आपको ओ टॉप 10 दिखेगा
यहां पे आप ओ टॉप 10 इसको जब ओपन कर
लीजिएगा तो यहां पे आप इसको भी कर लीजिएगा
ये पुराना वाला ओ टॉप 10 है यह 2017 वाला
होगा तो आप इसको भी पढ़ लीजिएगा क्योंकि
आपको पता होना चाहिए कि 2017 में जो
लेबिलिटी थी जो भी लिस्टेड थी वो उससे
कितना डिफरेंट है आपका 2021 वाला कितना
क्या चेंजेज आए हैं तो आप ये दोनों मशीनस
को जो है ना सॉल्व कर लीजिएगा सॉल्व करने
का मतलब यहां पे सिंपल है इसको पढ़
लीजिएगा कंप्लीटेड कर दीजिएगा ओ टॉप 10
एंड ओ टॉप 10
2021 ओके यह टास्क है आप लोगों का आई होप
एवरीवन विल कंप्लीट दिस टास्क बिफोर द
नेक्स्ट सेशन आई होप सभी लोग इसको नेक्स्ट
सेशन से पहले कंप्लीट करेंगे मैं ऐसा
उम्मीद करता
हूं ठीक है थैंक यू वेरी मच एंड जब भी आप
टास्क कंप्लीट करेंगे मैं आपको बता देता
हूं मैं आपको सुनो सुनो सुनो सुनो मैं
आपको समझा देता हूं यार क्या समझा देता
हूं मैं आपको बता देता
हूं जब भी आप टास्क कंप्लीट करेंगे तो आप
उसको लैब को फोटो क्लिक करेंगे कंप्लीटेड
का जब आ जाएगा तो एंड आप
ये आपका व्यू एज मेंबर देखो यहां पे डिक्स
करके आएगा कंपनी स् डेनिक्स आप टैग कर
देना एंड देन मुझे भी पता चलता रहेगा आपके
बारे में कि भैया आप क्या कर रहे हैं ठीक
है गॉट इट एवरीवन ये आपका टास्क है एक ये
टास्क आपको करना है एंड आपको मैंने आज
बताया कैसे एक राइट टारगेट चूज करनी है बग
बांटी के लिए बहुत ही क्रिटिकल बहुत ही
इंपॉर्टेंट स्टेप होता है कि स्कोप कैसे
पब्लिक प्राइवेट रिवर्ड बाउंट ट्रायक
कंपनी स्किल्स के अकॉर्डिंग वेब प कौन सा
एप्लीकेशन क्या एसेट फाइंडर टूल का यूज आप
कर सकते हो हम उसको पब्लिक हम उसको करेंगे
परफॉर्म कोई टेंशन नहीं लेनी है और
देख लो ऐसा मत बोलना कि सर डाला ही
नहीं ये कंटेंट वाले में जाना एंड्राइड
वाली बाद में आएगी भाई एंड वाली बाद में
आएगी टेंशन मत लो कंटेंट में यह फ्री वाली
में चले जाना मोबाइल एप्लीकेशन के अंदर
में यह फ्री वाली कोर्स जो है आपकी आपने
जवाइन कर रखा होगा तो कंटेंट को आप देख
सकते हैं वहां से यूज कर सकते हैं एंड
यहां पर आप चले जाना बग बाउंट रिसोर्सेस
में तो आपको चीट सट डाली है चेकलिस्ट डाली
है आज मैं आपको डॉक भी डाल दूंगा और इसमें
जो है ना फ्री
सोर्सेस इसमें आपको बब शूट का प्रो वर्जन
मिल जाएगा जिफ फाइल आपको मिल जाएगी आप
उसको डाउनलोड करके उसको
आप
कॉन्फिन कॉन्फिन यूज ठीक है हालाकि मैं
बताऊंगा आपको अगर कुछ प्रॉब्लम होगी तो
आपको वो भी समझा द ठीक है ओके प्राइम ओके
यार डोंट डोंट
वो स्पैम मत करो प्राइम भाई यह प्राइम भाई
यार बहुत स्पैम करते हैं स्पैम मत कीजिए
आपको थोड़ा देर फिर आपको होल्ड करना
पड़ेगा मुझे मुझे आपको टाइम आउट प डाल
देना पड़ेगा 10 मिनट के लिए चलिए आपको
मैंने टा टाइम आउट प डाल दिया 10 मिनट के
लिए क्योंकि आपने बहुत स्पैम किया है तो
दैट्ची बात है बाकी ये हमारे सोशल
प्लेटफॉर्म्स है आप कनेक्ट हो सकते हैं हम
पे इन पे फॉलो कर सकते हैं रेगुलर अपडेट्स
के लिए
पे मिल रहे हैं भाई वहीं पे आपको सारे
अपडेट्स मिलेंगे वो जवाइन कर लीजिएगा एंड
एज यूजुअल ये हमारे सोशल हैंडल्स हैं एंड
ये हमारी एक हैकिंग की कोर्स है ये बहुत
सारे लोगों ने लिया है इफ यू वांट इफ यू
आर इंटरेस्टेड यू कैन गो एंड इनरोल टू दिस
url.com साइबर सिक्योरिटी मास्टरी कोर्स
एंड या फिर आपको इसी डिस्क्रिप्शन में मिल
जाएगा एंड आप अपनी एथिकल हैकिंग साइबर
सिक्योरिटी की जर्नी को स्टार्ट कर सकते
हैं तो आज के सेशन के लिए फिलहाल इतना ही
गाइस एंड सबको बहुत-बहुत धन्यवाद
बहुत-बहुत धन्यवाद आप इतने सारे लोग
जुड़ते हैं आए हैं इट्स अ वेरी अ वेरी
लाइक गुड फीलिंग मतलब एक अच्छी फीलिंग है
कि आप इतने लोग आ रहे हो भाई 100 प्लस लोग
आ रहे हैं बहुत बड़ी बात है भाई इतने लोग
इंटरेस्टेड हैं
दैट्ची को बना के रखोगे तभी मजा आएगा अगर
इसको तुम कंसिस्टेंटली बढ़ के रखो ना इस
प्रेजेंस को तो मुझे आपसे ज्यादा मजा आएगा
ज्यादा तो मैं एक्साइटेड रहूंगा तो तुम बस
ये कंसिस्टेंट रहो हर लाइफ में ऐसे ही
आओगे पक्का श्यर है ना हर एक लाइव में सभी
आओगे मुझे लास्ट ये चीज बता दो फिर मैं
एंड करता हूं बता दो
मुझे जल्दी बताओ हर लाइफ में आओगे ऐसे ही
सारे विद
कंसिस्टेंटली मतलब पूरी कंसिस्टेंसी के
साथ
आओगे
ओके वेलकम वेलकम
राजू अरे मैं तो आऊंगा भाई तुम लोग आओ
मैं तो आऊंगा ही यार तुम लोग
आओ
ओके अहमद राजा ट सर व्ट विल वी डू वी आर
फ्रॉम डिफरेंट कंट्री उससे कोई दिक्कत तो
नहीं होगी शायद डिफरेंट कंट्री होने से ना
कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है क्या प्रॉब्लम आ रही
है आपकी अहमद राजा डिफरेंट कंट्री होने से
मैं समझा नहीं ओके नेक्स्ट लाइव का कब
होगी ट चैनल में पता चलेगा में जाओ इसी
लाइव के वहां ैनो को जवाइन कर लो मोस्ट
प्रोबेबली परसों ही होगी ठीक है तो जवाइन
कर लो चलो तो अभी के लिए सबको टाटा बाय
बाय एंड थैंक यू सो मच फॉर जॉइनिंग एंड
हैव अ गुड डे
गाइस सबको हैव गुड नाइट एक्चुअली अभी नाइट
हो रही है तो हैव अ गुड नाइट